All right. So, we're going to do another
All right. So, we're going to do another episode today of AI that works with
episode today of AI that works with
episode today of AI that works with myself and
myself and
myself and Dexter. And last week, we talked about
Dexter. And last week, we talked about
Dexter. And last week, we talked about how to do classification with a thousand
how to do classification with a thousand
how to do classification with a thousand plus classes. And this week, we want to
plus classes. And this week, we want to
plus classes. And this week, we want to talk about something I thought was
talk about something I thought was
talk about something I thought was really relevant, especially with all the
really relevant, especially with all the
really relevant, especially with all the new models coming out recently. Uh,
new models coming out recently. Uh,
new models coming out recently. Uh, Llama 4 came out, a few other approaches
Llama 4 came out, a few other approaches
Llama 4 came out, a few other approaches came out. And the things that we want to
came out. And the things that we want to
came out. And the things that we want to spend the most time on is how do these
spend the most time on is how do these
spend the most time on is how do these reasoning models actually help us? Do
reasoning models actually help us? Do
reasoning models actually help us? Do they help us? Is there an advantage to
they help us? Is there an advantage to
they help us? Is there an advantage to using them? Is there an advantage to not
using them? Is there an advantage to not
using them? Is there an advantage to not using them? Um, could we leverage some
using them? Um, could we leverage some
using them? Um, could we leverage some of the reasoning capabilities in
of the reasoning capabilities in
of the reasoning capabilities in existing models without using a
existing models without using a
existing models without using a reasoning model? Um, and with that,
reasoning model? Um, and with that,
reasoning model? Um, and with that, let's go off and start talking about
let's go off and start talking about
let's go off and start talking about some of the stuff. But as we always say,
some of the stuff. But as we always say,
some of the stuff. But as we always say, it's really hard to go and have a
it's really hard to go and have a
it's really hard to go and have a conversation about these techniques that
conversation about these techniques that
conversation about these techniques that seem so
seem so
seem so abstract without actually a concrete
abstract without actually a concrete
abstract without actually a concrete example. So, Dex here has put together a
example. So, Dex here has put together a
example. So, Dex here has put together a really, really good example. uh that I
really, really good example. uh that I
really, really good example. uh that I think is going to be helpful and
think is going to be helpful and
think is going to be helpful and somewhat um good grounding for all of us
somewhat um good grounding for all of us
somewhat um good grounding for all of us to talk about. So we're going to talk
to talk about. So we're going to talk
to talk about. So we're going to talk about the example first and then dive
about the example first and then dive
about the example first and then dive into the reasoning
into the reasoning
into the reasoning capabilities. You want to take it away
capabilities. You want to take it away
capabilities. You want to take it away next? Yeah, let's do it. Um so we have
next? Yeah, let's do it. Um so we have
next? Yeah, let's do it. Um so we have built um really quickly there is a
built um really quickly there is a
built um really quickly there is a public neo forj database for movie
public neo forj database for movie
public neo forj database for movie recommendations. So this is just a
recommendations. So this is just a
recommendations. So this is just a public data set. Anyone can plug into
public data set. Anyone can plug into
public data set. Anyone can plug into it. It's kind of got like public
it. It's kind of got like public
it. It's kind of got like public username and password. And we've just
username and password. And we've just
username and password. And we've just built a small little AI agent that can
built a small little AI agent that can
built a small little AI agent that can answer questions about movies. And it's
answer questions about movies. And it's
answer questions about movies. And it's using agentic tool calling to generate
using agentic tool calling to generate
using agentic tool calling to generate cipher queries to query against the
cipher queries to query against the
cipher queries to query against the database for and cipher is the um name
database for and cipher is the um name
database for and cipher is the um name of the SQLish dialect that they use. So
of the SQLish dialect that they use. So
of the SQLish dialect that they use. So I can ask this thing something like hey
I can ask this thing something like hey
I can ask this thing something like hey who's in point
who's in point
who's in point break and we see it gets back and it
break and we see it gets back and it
break and we see it gets back and it runs this query and then you can see
runs this query and then you can see
runs this query and then you can see kind of what came back from the database
kind of what came back from the database
kind of what came back from the database and it gives you the main actors and so
and it gives you the main actors and so
and it gives you the main actors and so you can ask it even more complex queries
you can ask it even more complex queries
you can ask it even more complex queries like what else are they in
like what else are they in
like what else are they in um and it gets this very
um and it gets this very
um and it gets this very long pile of JSON.
long pile of JSON.
long pile of JSON. Um, one of the challenges with this is,
Um, one of the challenges with this is,
Um, one of the challenges with this is, uh, you'll notice, uh, it's just not
uh, you'll notice, uh, it's just not
uh, you'll notice, uh, it's just not that smart in certain cases. Uh, so if I
that smart in certain cases. Uh, so if I
that smart in certain cases. Uh, so if I say who's in the matrix,
say who's in the matrix,
say who's in the matrix, um, it's going to run this query and
um, it's going to run this query and
um, it's going to run this query and it's going to get it wrong and it's just
it's going to get it wrong and it's just
it's going to get it wrong and it's just going to keep trying over and over again
going to keep trying over and over again
going to keep trying over and over again until it breaks. Um, but I can come back
until it breaks. Um, but I can come back
until it breaks. Um, but I can come back here and say like who's in matrix the
here and say like who's in matrix the
here and say like who's in matrix the and then eventually it'll figure it out
and then eventually it'll figure it out
and then eventually it'll figure it out and get the right title. Um, so there's
and get the right title. Um, so there's
and get the right title. Um, so there's some interesting things around like
some interesting things around like
some interesting things around like giving it correct like directions and
giving it correct like directions and
giving it correct like directions and instructions to follow that I think
instructions to follow that I think
instructions to follow that I think we're I think we're using 40 mini right
we're I think we're using 40 mini right
we're I think we're using 40 mini right now. Um, but we'll get into kind of some
now. Um, but we'll get into kind of some
now. Um, but we'll get into kind of some of the interesting challenges uh with
of the interesting challenges uh with
of the interesting challenges uh with how to how to get this thing to do. So
how to how to get this thing to do. So
how to how to get this thing to do. So for like writing SQL, writing code, and
for like writing SQL, writing code, and
for like writing SQL, writing code, and other types of tasks that like reasoning
other types of tasks that like reasoning
other types of tasks that like reasoning models tend to be much better at. Um,
models tend to be much better at. Um,
models tend to be much better at. Um, we'll look at kind of hey, let's drop in
we'll look at kind of hey, let's drop in
we'll look at kind of hey, let's drop in a reasoning model and and see how how
a reasoning model and and see how how
a reasoning model and and see how how powerful this is. And then we'll uh dig
powerful this is. And then we'll uh dig
powerful this is. And then we'll uh dig into some techniques for hey, how can
into some techniques for hey, how can
into some techniques for hey, how can you use smaller models or non-reasoning
you use smaller models or non-reasoning
you use smaller models or non-reasoning models and uh build your own reasoning
models and uh build your own reasoning
models and uh build your own reasoning pipeline um and kind of what's happening
pipeline um and kind of what's happening
pipeline um and kind of what's happening under the hood there. So the code for
under the hood there. So the code for
under the hood there. So the code for this is in the repo. Um we'll add some
this is in the repo. Um we'll add some
this is in the repo. Um we'll add some more outlines and stuff to this as we
more outlines and stuff to this as we
more outlines and stuff to this as we go. Um but like five, what do you want
go. Um but like five, what do you want
go. Um but like five, what do you want to do? You want to jump into like the
to do? You want to jump into like the
to do? You want to jump into like the architecture of just what's going on in
architecture of just what's going on in
architecture of just what's going on in the inside? Yeah, I think let's just
the inside? Yeah, I think let's just
the inside? Yeah, I think let's just grab a whiteboard and just really
grab a whiteboard and just really
grab a whiteboard and just really quickly outline the code that we have
quickly outline the code that we have
quickly outline the code that we have today. Once we have the code that we
today. Once we have the code that we
today. Once we have the code that we have today um and then we can go ahead
have today um and then we can go ahead
have today um and then we can go ahead and kind of go from here and uh uh talk
and kind of go from here and uh uh talk
and kind of go from here and uh uh talk about the reasoning structure. Yeah,
about the reasoning structure. Yeah,
about the reasoning structure. Yeah, cool. So, um I think the core of this is
cool. So, um I think the core of this is
cool. So, um I think the core of this is just the chat loop.
just the chat loop.
just the chat loop. [Music]
[Music]
[Music] Um so, uh essentially what we've got
Um so, uh essentially what we've got
Um so, uh essentially what we've got here is we've got this big for loop. Um
here is we've got this big for loop. Um
here is we've got this big for loop. Um I'm actually going to draw this out. So,
I'm actually going to draw this out. So,
I'm actually going to draw this out. So, a message comes in from the front end,
a message comes in from the front end,
a message comes in from the front end, from the
from the
from the user. Um, and uh, Vibob, I also sent you
user. Um, and uh, Vibob, I also sent you
user. Um, and uh, Vibob, I also sent you I I just shot you a link to this
I I just shot you a link to this
I I just shot you a link to this whiteboard as well.
whiteboard as well.
whiteboard as well. Um, and we basically going to pass that
Um, and we basically going to pass that
Um, and we basically going to pass that into our prompt um, that we called chat
into our prompt um, that we called chat
into our prompt um, that we called chat with
with
with graph. Um, so you can see that is
graph. Um, so you can see that is
graph. Um, so you can see that is uh, as you may expect a BAML function.
uh, as you may expect a BAML function.
uh, as you may expect a BAML function. Um, actually, let me just pull up the
Um, actually, let me just pull up the
Um, actually, let me just pull up the actual
actual
actual code. Um,
wonderful. Okay, cool. So, um, we're
wonderful. Okay, cool. So, um, we're basically asking it, hey, try to help
basically asking it, hey, try to help
basically asking it, hey, try to help the user out. We give it the schema of
the user out. We give it the schema of
the user out. We give it the schema of the database which is
the database which is
the database which is um a big file that looks like this that
um a big file that looks like this that
um a big file that looks like this that just describes the different nodes in
just describes the different nodes in
just describes the different nodes in the graph. Um, and then for each
the graph. Um, and then for each
the graph. Um, and then for each message, we put that in. And then we put
message, we put that in. And then we put
message, we put that in. And then we put in a system message that basically asks
in a system message that basically asks
in a system message that basically asks it to output things in a specific
it to output things in a specific
it to output things in a specific format. And our response is either going
format. And our response is either going
format. And our response is either going to be a, you know, string, hey, here's
to be a, you know, string, hey, here's
to be a, you know, string, hey, here's your answer um, action reply, or
your answer um, action reply, or
your answer um, action reply, or um, it's going to be a graph query where
um, it's going to be a graph query where
um, it's going to be a graph query where it's going to tell us what query it
it's going to tell us what query it
it's going to tell us what query it wants to run. So, those are the two
wants to run. So, those are the two
wants to run. So, those are the two options. And we're basically going to
options. And we're basically going to
options. And we're basically going to ask the model to output one of those two
ask the model to output one of those two
ask the model to output one of those two things. If it outputs a graph query um
things. If it outputs a graph query um
things. If it outputs a graph query um we will we will go run that tool. Um so
we will we will go run that tool. Um so
we will we will go run that tool. Um so let's say it outputs you
let's say it outputs you
let's say it outputs you know query
know query
know query graph then we actually go connect to the
graph then we actually go connect to the
graph then we actually go connect to the neo forj database
uh and then we add to what we call the
uh and then we add to what we call the working context here. Thank
working context here. Thank
working context here. Thank you. Right. So it starts with the user
you. Right. So it starts with the user
you. Right. So it starts with the user message and
message and
message and then we will append to the working
then we will append to the working
then we will append to the working context query graph with actually like
context query graph with actually like
context query graph with actually like the the cipher that it uh
selected and then we add the neo forj
selected and then we add the neo forj result neo forj result
result neo forj result
result neo forj result um including if there was an error there
um including if there was an error there
um including if there was an error there or something like that.
or something like that.
or something like that. Um, and then we basically pass that back
Um, and then we basically pass that back
Um, and then we basically pass that back into the LLM and it may decide, oh, if
into the LLM and it may decide, oh, if
into the LLM and it may decide, oh, if there's an error or it didn't get any
there's an error or it didn't get any
there's an error or it didn't get any results, um, we saw in the matrix
results, um, we saw in the matrix
results, um, we saw in the matrix example, it just kept trying the same
example, it just kept trying the same
example, it just kept trying the same thing again as 40in is want to do. So,
thing again as 40in is want to do. So,
thing again as 40in is want to do. So, it may loop back through this way or it
it may loop back through this way or it
it may loop back through this way or it may at some point realize, okay, cool.
may at some point realize, okay, cool.
may at some point realize, okay, cool. I'm done calling tools and I want to
I'm done calling tools and I want to
I'm done calling tools and I want to just
just
just reply. And then at that point, we kind
reply. And then at that point, we kind
reply. And then at that point, we kind of exit out and send that reply back to
of exit out and send that reply back to
of exit out and send that reply back to the user. And while these are happening,
the user. And while these are happening,
the user. And while these are happening, we're also streaming those back into the
we're also streaming those back into the
we're also streaming those back into the uh into the kind of context window. You
uh into the kind of context window. You
uh into the kind of context window. You got it. I'm just trying to make a curved
got it. I'm just trying to make a curved
got it. I'm just trying to make a curved arm line really fast here. I got
arm line really fast here. I got
arm line really fast here. I got you like that. Yeah, exactly. Yeah.
you like that. Yeah, exactly. Yeah.
you like that. Yeah, exactly. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah.
Yeah. Cool. Uh does that make sense?
Cool. Uh does that make sense?
Cool. Uh does that make sense? Questions?
Um I'll just recap really fast um on
Um I'll just recap really fast um on this really fast. Um, so the idea is
this really fast. Um, so the idea is
this really fast. Um, so the idea is basically that if an LLM is going to go
basically that if an LLM is going to go
basically that if an LLM is going to go reply to something, we want to be able
reply to something, we want to be able
reply to something, we want to be able to iterate on iterably over time in this
to iterate on iterably over time in this
to iterate on iterably over time in this sort of approach as what Dex showed. And
sort of approach as what Dex showed. And
sort of approach as what Dex showed. And if we can't iterate on it, then the
if we can't iterate on it, then the
if we can't iterate on it, then the problem is we rely on the model to be
problem is we rely on the model to be
problem is we rely on the model to be perfectly correct. So the front end
perfectly correct. So the front end
perfectly correct. So the front end really doesn't care about any of these
really doesn't care about any of these
really doesn't care about any of these things. And the reason that the code
things. And the reason that the code
things. And the reason that the code that you see is a little bit more
that you see is a little bit more
that you see is a little bit more complicated is because what we're
complicated is because what we're
complicated is because what we're actually doing under the hood is every
actually doing under the hood is every
actually doing under the hood is every single time we add something to the
single time we add something to the
single time we add something to the working context, we're also streaming an
working context, we're also streaming an
working context, we're also streaming an event out to the front
event out to the front
event out to the front end, letting it know what we're doing to
end, letting it know what we're doing to
end, letting it know what we're doing to the working context. So the user doesn't
the working context. So the user doesn't
the working context. So the user doesn't actually see an opaque block until we
actually see an opaque block until we
actually see an opaque block until we reply. The user is actually seeing the
reply. The user is actually seeing the
reply. The user is actually seeing the the working context as it's happening.
the working context as it's happening.
the working context as it's happening. And there's interesting things that we
And there's interesting things that we
And there's interesting things that we can do in the front end if we wanted to,
can do in the front end if we wanted to,
can do in the front end if we wanted to, which is once the front end is actually
which is once the front end is actually
which is once the front end is actually done, we could technically just delete
done, we could technically just delete
done, we could technically just delete the working context and only show the
the working context and only show the
the working context and only show the reply. So, so the user doesn't have to
reply. So, so the user doesn't have to
reply. So, so the user doesn't have to know that it can see like it's an in
know that it can see like it's an in
know that it can see like it's an in progress training. That's a front end
progress training. That's a front end
progress training. That's a front end only query that we could like we could
only query that we could like we could
only query that we could like we could hide. Go ahead. So, we did like who's in
hide. Go ahead. So, we did like who's in
hide. Go ahead. So, we did like who's in uh who's got a good movie.
uh who's got a good movie.
uh who's got a good movie. Um, finding Nemo. That's
Um, finding Nemo. That's
Um, finding Nemo. That's great. I just thought about it.
great. I just thought about it.
great. I just thought about it. Um um yeah so like our working context
Um um yeah so like our working context
Um um yeah so like our working context is this query and the response and then
is this query and the response and then
is this query and the response and then here's our final answer and I think the
here's our final answer and I think the
here's our final answer and I think the implementation right is that actually
implementation right is that actually
implementation right is that actually even when I ask another question this
even when I ask another question this
even when I ask another question this gets cleared out of the context window
gets cleared out of the context window
gets cleared out of the context window right the steps and we only just see the
right the steps and we only just see the
right the steps and we only just see the messages that have happened right
messages that have happened right
messages that have happened right exactly
exactly
exactly so the idea is that over time the chat
so the idea is that over time the chat
so the idea is that over time the chat doesn't need to preserve all the cipher
doesn't need to preserve all the cipher
doesn't need to preserve all the cipher queries that I have it just kind of
queries that I have it just kind of
queries that I have it just kind of needs to preserve the answer
needs to preserve the answer
needs to preserve the answer um so like on the X chat, we still send
um so like on the X chat, we still send
um so like on the X chat, we still send the whole contacts window, but we
the whole contacts window, but we
the whole contacts window, but we actually clear these things out. And so
actually clear these things out. And so
actually clear these things out. And so you just have the reply and then the
you just have the reply and then the
you just have the reply and then the user message. And then as we're building
user message. And then as we're building
user message. And then as we're building up the continued working context, it may
up the continued working context, it may
up the continued working context, it may have a bunch of queries here until we
have a bunch of queries here until we
have a bunch of queries here until we get to the next reply and then these get
get to the next reply and then these get
get to the next reply and then these get crossed out again. Exactly. You nailed
crossed out again. Exactly. You nailed
crossed out again. Exactly. You nailed it, Dex. So can I ask a quick question
it, Dex. So can I ask a quick question
it, Dex. So can I ask a quick question about that?
about that?
about that? So I've been doing similar queries with
So I've been doing similar queries with
So I've been doing similar queries with uh Neo4j and GraphQL as well. Is there
uh Neo4j and GraphQL as well. Is there
uh Neo4j and GraphQL as well. Is there any advantage keeping the context around
any advantage keeping the context around
any advantage keeping the context around to help correct it? So I found like
to help correct it? So I found like
to help correct it? So I found like sometimes you can't get that first shot
sometimes you can't get that first shot
sometimes you can't get that first shot of a query. You prompt it and then it
of a query. You prompt it and then it
of a query. You prompt it and then it gets the right one. Have you have you
gets the right one. Have you have you
gets the right one. Have you have you noticed that pattern? So here's what we
noticed that pattern? So here's what we
noticed that pattern? So here's what we actually do under the hood. So whenever
actually do under the hood. So whenever
actually do under the hood. So whenever this Neo4j result comes, this Neo4j
this Neo4j result comes, this Neo4j
this Neo4j result comes, this Neo4j result could be either green because it
result could be either green because it
result could be either green because it actually solved it or it could be red
actually solved it or it could be red
actually solved it or it could be red because it doesn't have the answer. If
because it doesn't have the answer. If
because it doesn't have the answer. If it's red, we literally what we really do
it's red, we literally what we really do
it's red, we literally what we really do is like if this sorry I'll I'll write
is like if this sorry I'll I'll write
is like if this sorry I'll I'll write this as an error. What we really inject
this as an error. What we really inject
this as an error. What we really inject is something that looks like this.
You could imagine injecting something
You could imagine injecting something like this where you just say oops an
like this where you just say oops an
like this where you just say oops an error happened add it to the context and
error happened add it to the context and
error happened add it to the context and now send it back to the model and the
now send it back to the model and the
now send it back to the model and the model now generates a new query which we
model now generates a new query which we
model now generates a new query which we then get a new neoforj call oops which
then get a new neoforj call oops which
then get a new neoforj call oops which we get a new neoforj call and if it's
we get a new neoforj call and if it's
we get a new neoforj call and if it's another error then we keep on adding it
another error then we keep on adding it
another error then we keep on adding it um but if it's not an error it's
um but if it's not an error it's
um but if it's not an error it's actually a result then we add the result
actually a result then we add the result
actually a result then we add the result and then we ask the model to go again
and then we ask the model to go again
and then we ask the model to go again but anytime it's not an error what we do
but anytime it's not an error what we do
but anytime it's not an error what we do is we actually delete all the previous
is we actually delete all the previous
is we actually delete all the previous queries and all the previous context and
queries and all the previous context and
queries and all the previous context and just add it in like this.
just add it in like this.
just add it in like this. Gotcha. Okay, that makes sense. And that
Gotcha. Okay, that makes sense. And that
Gotcha. Okay, that makes sense. And that that error as you called it, there's
that error as you called it, there's
that error as you called it, there's obviously like a a UI a user could
obviously like a a UI a user could
obviously like a a UI a user could interject and say, "Hey, you got it
interject and say, "Hey, you got it
interject and say, "Hey, you got it wrong." And that gives us this
wrong." And that gives us this
wrong." And that gives us this opportunity to develop that again,
opportunity to develop that again,
opportunity to develop that again, right? Well, we actually just let the
right? Well, we actually just let the
right? Well, we actually just let the model know that the errors happen like
model know that the errors happen like
model know that the errors happen like Neo4j is telling us the citra query is
Neo4j is telling us the citra query is
Neo4j is telling us the citra query is wrong. But I think this gets in Yeah,
wrong. But I think this gets in Yeah,
wrong. But I think this gets in Yeah, sorry. I think this gets into um kind of
sorry. I think this gets into um kind of
sorry. I think this gets into um kind of your point on the last episode as well,
your point on the last episode as well,
your point on the last episode as well, Vibb, which was basically like you can
Vibb, which was basically like you can
Vibb, which was basically like you can build whatever you want. And if you have
build whatever you want. And if you have
build whatever you want. And if you have things structured like this and you have
things structured like this and you have
things structured like this and you have each step and you have control over it,
each step and you have control over it,
each step and you have control over it, then yes, you could build something of
then yes, you could build something of
then yes, you could build something of like, oh, when we have two errors in a
like, oh, when we have two errors in a
like, oh, when we have two errors in a row, don't send it back to the model.
row, don't send it back to the model.
row, don't send it back to the model. Actually send it to the user, but keep
Actually send it to the user, but keep
Actually send it to the user, but keep those errors around and send a
those errors around and send a
those errors around and send a deterministic message to the user of
deterministic message to the user of
deterministic message to the user of like, hey, we've got two errors, like
like, hey, we've got two errors, like
like, hey, we've got two errors, like what do you want to do about it? And
what do you want to do about it? And
what do you want to do about it? And then append that rather, you know what I
then append that rather, you know what I
then append that rather, you know what I mean?
mean?
mean? Yeah. just I mean I guess there's
Yeah. just I mean I guess there's
Yeah. just I mean I guess there's there's two forms of error, right?
there's two forms of error, right?
there's two forms of error, right? There's the it created an invalid query.
There's the it created an invalid query.
There's the it created an invalid query. The other form is it got the query
The other form is it got the query
The other form is it got the query wrong. Um quite complex queries like you
wrong. Um quite complex queries like you
wrong. Um quite complex queries like you know um give me all the people who did
know um give me all the people who did
know um give me all the people who did this who are also starring in that who
this who are also starring in that who
this who are also starring in that who are friends with this. Um I find those
are friends with this. Um I find those
are friends with this. Um I find those queries can break down they break down
queries can break down they break down
queries can break down they break down slower in cipher than GraphQL. Um, yeah.
slower in cipher than GraphQL. Um, yeah.
slower in cipher than GraphQL. Um, yeah. But then a really easy thing you can do
But then a really easy thing you can do
But then a really easy thing you can do is like me and Dex talked about how you
is like me and Dex talked about how you
is like me and Dex talked about how you could delete the user messages and then
could delete the user messages and then
could delete the user messages and then add in a and we what we do is like we
add in a and we what we do is like we
add in a and we what we do is like we basically just delete the user message
basically just delete the user message
basically just delete the user message and we only add in the reply. You could
and we only add in the reply. You could
and we only add in the reply. You could say an if statement that says if the
say an if statement that says if the
say an if statement that says if the query is more than 5,000 characters then
query is more than 5,000 characters then
query is more than 5,000 characters then include
include
include it in the context window. It's a choice.
it in the context window. It's a choice.
it in the context window. It's a choice. Yeah. like the way you build the context
Yeah. like the way you build the context
Yeah. like the way you build the context for the user is really a choice of what
for the user is really a choice of what
for the user is really a choice of what you do.
you do.
you do. And if you go back to the UI dance,
And if you go back to the UI dance,
And if you go back to the UI dance, yeah, you could even do this in a
yeah, you could even do this in a
yeah, you could even do this in a different way where you could actually
different way where you could actually
different way where you could actually put checkboxes into your UI that says
put checkboxes into your UI that says
put checkboxes into your UI that says like should the should the model
like should the should the model
like should the should the model preserve this into the context or not.
preserve this into the context or not.
preserve this into the context or not. So you could even make it user driven
So you could even make it user driven
So you could even make it user driven about whether or not the queries are
about whether or not the queries are
about whether or not the queries are passed in. It's really turn your users
passed in. It's really turn your users
passed in. It's really turn your users into context engineers. Yeah, exactly.
into context engineers. Yeah, exactly.
into context engineers. Yeah, exactly. turning your users into context
turning your users into context
turning your users into context engineers along the way so they can make
engineers along the way so they can make
engineers along the way so they can make an educated decision. You can have good
an educated decision. You can have good
an educated decision. You can have good defaults like very long queries get
defaults like very long queries get
defaults like very long queries get added in very simple queries
added in very simple queries
added in very simple queries don't. Does that make sense u?
don't. Does that make sense u?
don't. Does that make sense u? Yeah definitely that's a that's a really
Yeah definitely that's a that's a really
Yeah definitely that's a that's a really clear way of looking at it. Thanks.
clear way of looking at it. Thanks.
clear way of looking at it. Thanks. Awesome. Um but now that we have this
Awesome. Um but now that we have this
Awesome. Um but now that we have this framework, I want to talk about the next
framework, I want to talk about the next
framework, I want to talk about the next part which is actually the reasoning
part which is actually the reasoning
part which is actually the reasoning models because we if without an example
models because we if without an example
models because we if without an example it seems really abstract on how do you
it seems really abstract on how do you
it seems really abstract on how do you go do this but let's talk about a little
go do this but let's talk about a little
go do this but let's talk about a little bit about what a reasoning model is in
bit about what a reasoning model is in
bit about what a reasoning model is in the first place.
the first place.
the first place. Um so uh D I'm going to go to the
Um so uh D I'm going to go to the
Um so uh D I'm going to go to the whiteboard really fast. I'm Oh yeah,
whiteboard really fast. I'm Oh yeah,
whiteboard really fast. I'm Oh yeah, let's do it. Yeah, sorry. Um okay. Yeah,
let's do it. Yeah, sorry. Um okay. Yeah,
let's do it. Yeah, sorry. Um okay. Yeah, because the whole point of this is less
because the whole point of this is less
because the whole point of this is less about this content. This is more just
about this content. This is more just
about this content. This is more just like setting the stage for how this
like setting the stage for how this
like setting the stage for how this thing works. So when you're reading the
thing works. So when you're reading the
thing works. So when you're reading the code, you get it. Because what we're
code, you get it. Because what we're
code, you get it. Because what we're going to go do is actually make this
going to go do is actually make this
going to go do is actually make this pipeline way more complex because like
pipeline way more complex because like
pipeline way more complex because like and
and
and like do some whiteboarding, but then
like do some whiteboarding, but then
like do some whiteboarding, but then like we're going to come up with some
like we're going to come up with some
like we're going to come up with some really interesting and complex questions
really interesting and complex questions
really interesting and complex questions that 40 mini is just like no way it's
that 40 mini is just like no way it's
that 40 mini is just like no way it's going to get the cipher query right.
going to get the cipher query right.
going to get the cipher query right. Yeah. So let's talk a little bit about
Yeah. So let's talk a little bit about
Yeah. So let's talk a little bit about what a reasoning model is and I think
what a reasoning model is and I think
what a reasoning model is and I think that's going to help us understand what
that's going to help us understand what
that's going to help us understand what they do under the hood and then we can
they do under the hood and then we can
they do under the hood and then we can talk about it. So, we all know what an
talk about it. So, we all know what an
talk about it. So, we all know what an uh uh well, okay, well, I'm assuming
uh uh well, okay, well, I'm assuming
uh uh well, okay, well, I'm assuming most people that come here know what an
most people that come here know what an
most people that come here know what an LLM is. It's a thing that takes in input
LLM is. It's a thing that takes in input
LLM is. It's a thing that takes in input tokens and then spits out
tokens and then spits out
tokens and then spits out Oh. Oh, interesting. inputs and arrow
Oh. Oh, interesting. inputs and arrow
Oh. Oh, interesting. inputs and arrow choice. Uh it's a thing that takes in um
choice. Uh it's a thing that takes in um
choice. Uh it's a thing that takes in um input tokens and then spits out another
input tokens and then spits out another
input tokens and then spits out another only a single token at at a time. And
only a single token at at a time. And
only a single token at at a time. And what we do is
uh interesting uh here I got you.
uh interesting uh here I got you. Yeah. Oh interest. Thank you. What we do
Yeah. Oh interest. Thank you. What we do
Yeah. Oh interest. Thank you. What we do under the hood is we keep on generating
under the hood is we keep on generating
under the hood is we keep on generating this as long as uh the token is not this
this as long as uh the token is not this
this as long as uh the token is not this special token called eof or uh there's
special token called eof or uh there's
special token called eof or uh there's some like we'll call it eof or eof which
some like we'll call it eof or eof which
some like we'll call it eof or eof which is some like termination token. If the
is some like termination token. If the
is some like termination token. If the token is a termination token, then we
token is a termination token, then we
token is a termination token, then we stop and then um and then we go do
stop and then um and then we go do
stop and then um and then we go do things.
things.
things. Now, let's talk about what a reasoning
Now, let's talk about what a reasoning
Now, let's talk about what a reasoning model does. A reasoning model does
model does. A reasoning model does
model does. A reasoning model does something very very very similar to
this. Um, and I'm not going to claim
this. Um, and I'm not going to claim that OpenAI does this exactly, but in
that OpenAI does this exactly, but in
that OpenAI does this exactly, but in theory it should be somewhat similar
theory it should be somewhat similar
theory it should be somewhat similar where there's a special token that we
where there's a special token that we
where there's a special token that we add into our So like we have an EOF
add into our So like we have an EOF
add into our So like we have an EOF token, we actually add in another
token, we actually add in another
token, we actually add in another special token that the model is allowed
special token that the model is allowed
special token that the model is allowed to generate that looks like
to generate that looks like
to generate that looks like this. Reason start. There's like a
this. Reason start. There's like a
this. Reason start. There's like a couple tokens that it's allowed to do.
couple tokens that it's allowed to do.
couple tokens that it's allowed to do. Reasoning
Reasoning
Reasoning start, reasoning
N. Like this. Got it. So the model is
N. Like this. Got it. So the model is actually deciding when its reasoning
actually deciding when its reasoning
actually deciding when its reasoning starts and oops I spelled reasoning
starts and oops I spelled reasoning
starts and oops I spelled reasoning wrong. The model is to some degree
wrong. The model is to some degree
wrong. The model is to some degree deciding what when the reasoning will
deciding what when the reasoning will
deciding what when the reasoning will start and end and if it should reason at
start and end and if it should reason at
start and end and if it should reason at all. The model may not generate the
all. The model may not generate the
all. The model may not generate the reasoning start token. Now I as open AI
reasoning start token. Now I as open AI
reasoning start token. Now I as open AI could enforce that the model generate
could enforce that the model generate
could enforce that the model generate the reasoning start token and it has to
the reasoning start token and it has to
the reasoning start token and it has to reason no matter what. So this first
reason no matter what. So this first
reason no matter what. So this first token, in fact, my input token could
token, in fact, my input token could
token, in fact, my input token could just be when I start off, like when I
just be when I start off, like when I
just be when I start off, like when I have my text, I could do text plus
have my text, I could do text plus
have my text, I could do text plus reasoning
start. Yeah. Have you seen I feel like
start. Yeah. Have you seen I feel like I've seen people like prompt engineering
I've seen people like prompt engineering
I've seen people like prompt engineering with like either like, you know, doing
with like either like, you know, doing
with like either like, you know, doing the oh, but wait inside the thinking or
the oh, but wait inside the thinking or
the oh, but wait inside the thinking or doing the like Yeah. just starting the
doing the like Yeah. just starting the
doing the like Yeah. just starting the thinking and then passing all of that
thinking and then passing all of that
thinking and then passing all of that into the LLM where it's like you
into the LLM where it's like you
into the LLM where it's like you actually you write the first three
actually you write the first three
actually you write the first three sentences of thinking yourself
sentences of thinking yourself
sentences of thinking yourself put it on a certain path even if you
put it on a certain path even if you
put it on a certain path even if you actually write the first three sentences
actually write the first three sentences
actually write the first three sentences of thinking just remember that the model
of thinking just remember that the model
of thinking just remember that the model provider itself actually has to do the
provider itself actually has to do the
provider itself actually has to do the thinking themselves the model provider
thinking themselves the model provider
thinking themselves the model provider is actually the one doing the thinking
is actually the one doing the thinking
is actually the one doing the thinking so the model provider is the one doing
so the model provider is the one doing
so the model provider is the one doing thinking even if you write the thinking
thinking even if you write the thinking
thinking even if you write the thinking text yourself you write something like
text yourself you write something like
text yourself you write something like um prompt
um prompt
um prompt And then you can write something like
this. You can write thinking and then
this. You can write thinking and then you can say blah blah blah. You'll go
you can say blah blah blah. You'll go
you can say blah blah blah. You'll go write your thinking part over here.
write your thinking part over here.
write your thinking part over here. Eventually the model provider will add a
Eventually the model provider will add a
Eventually the model provider will add a special token
special token
special token called reasoning start of some kind that
called reasoning start of some kind that
called reasoning start of some kind that is not under your control. Oh,
is not under your control. Oh,
is not under your control. Oh, interesting. Cannot make all of it
interesting. Cannot make all of it
interesting. Cannot make all of it orange.
um that is not under your
um that is not under your control that they control that adds it
control that they control that adds it
control that they control that adds it in. So technically your thinking part
in. So technically your thinking part
in. So technically your thinking part looks still more like the prompt than
looks still more like the prompt than
looks still more like the prompt than the actual reasoning part of the base.
the actual reasoning part of the base.
the actual reasoning part of the base. Oh, I see. They don't actually let you
Oh, I see. They don't actually let you
Oh, I see. They don't actually let you input the reasoning token. Exactly.
input the reasoning token. Exactly.
input the reasoning token. Exactly. Because there's there's a token that
Because there's there's a token that
Because there's there's a token that indicates that the reasoning starts. Now
indicates that the reasoning starts. Now
indicates that the reasoning starts. Now it's possible that this is an
it's possible that this is an
it's possible that this is an implementation detail and they don't
implementation detail and they don't
implementation detail and they don't actually need the reasoning start but
actually need the reasoning start but
actually need the reasoning start but they probably need some token to
they probably need some token to
they probably need some token to indicate that the reasoning is hap that
indicate that the reasoning is hap that
indicate that the reasoning is hap that this is a reasoning segment. It's e it's
this is a reasoning segment. It's e it's
this is a reasoning segment. It's e it's going to be easier to train the model if
going to be easier to train the model if
going to be easier to train the model if it knows that these are reasoning
it knows that these are reasoning
it knows that these are reasoning chunks. Yeah. Um and then the model will
chunks. Yeah. Um and then the model will
chunks. Yeah. Um and then the model will generate a bunch of text down
generate a bunch of text down
generate a bunch of text down here. Uh and I'm going to make this
here. Uh and I'm going to make this
here. Uh and I'm going to make this white because this is this is regular
white because this is this is regular
white because this is this is regular generation. So we can think of purple as
generation. So we can think of purple as
generation. So we can think of purple as inputs from a user. We can think of blue
inputs from a user. We can think of blue
inputs from a user. We can think of blue as
as
as um uh reasoning. So it's just like
um uh reasoning. So it's just like
um uh reasoning. So it's just like regular text that the model generates.
regular text that the model generates.
regular text that the model generates. Then the model will generate another
Then the model will generate another
Then the model will generate another special piece of
text and then the model will generate
text and then the model will generate more
more
more text, right? And this is really what a
text, right? And this is really what a
text, right? And this is really what a reasoning model to some degree is doing
reasoning model to some degree is doing
reasoning model to some degree is doing under the hood. And what the model is
under the hood. And what the model is
under the hood. And what the model is trained to do is it's trained to
trained to do is it's trained to
trained to do is it's trained to understand the meaning of these two
understand the meaning of these two
understand the meaning of these two tokens as being like extremely useful.
tokens as being like extremely useful.
tokens as being like extremely useful. If you think about what the model can do
If you think about what the model can do
If you think about what the model can do now is in the training loop, someone can
now is in the training loop, someone can
now is in the training loop, someone can go ahead and go train the model to go
go ahead and go train the model to go
go ahead and go train the model to go say that uh how do I do can you do a
say that uh how do I do can you do a
say that uh how do I do can you do a curve thing again? Sorry.
curve thing again? Sorry.
curve thing again? Sorry. Yeah. uh
Yeah. uh
Yeah. uh someone can actually train the model to
someone can actually train the model to
someone can actually train the model to say that hey the text that lives between
say that hey the text that lives between
say that hey the text that lives between reasoning start and reasoning end is
reasoning start and reasoning end is
reasoning start and reasoning end is actually highly informative and you
actually highly informative and you
actually highly informative and you should consider that a lot when you uh
should consider that a lot when you uh
should consider that a lot when you uh make decisions on what text to generate
make decisions on what text to generate
make decisions on what text to generate next right draws a lot of weight from
next right draws a lot of weight from
next right draws a lot of weight from the like attention mechanism exactly and
the like attention mechanism exactly and
the like attention mechanism exactly and that's a thing that the model could just
that's a thing that the model could just
that's a thing that the model could just be fine-tuned to go do uh and that's
be fine-tuned to go do uh and that's
be fine-tuned to go do uh and that's really what fundamentally what a
really what fundamentally what a
really what fundamentally what a reasoning model is doing under the hood
reasoning model is doing under the hood
reasoning model is doing under the hood and again can't really claim to know
and again can't really claim to know
and again can't really claim to know exactly what models do. Uh it is very
exactly what models do. Uh it is very
exactly what models do. Uh it is very hard to go predict anything about
hard to go predict anything about
hard to go predict anything about models. Well, we've been doing parts of
models. Well, we've been doing parts of
models. Well, we've been doing parts of this in prompts since way before it was
this in prompts since way before it was
this in prompts since way before it was like baked into the model, right? You
like baked into the model, right? You
like baked into the model, right? You could like ask it like, "Hey, always
could like ask it like, "Hey, always
could like ask it like, "Hey, always think about what to do, step one, step
think about what to do, step one, step
think about what to do, step one, step two, step three, and then give your
two, step three, and then give your
two, step three, and then give your answer." And some models that are good
answer." And some models that are good
answer." And some models that are good at instruction following might actually
at instruction following might actually
at instruction following might actually just like it's not fine-tuned to trust
just like it's not fine-tuned to trust
just like it's not fine-tuned to trust that stuff more, but it does you do
that stuff more, but it does you do
that stuff more, but it does you do force it to kind of like expand out on
force it to kind of like expand out on
force it to kind of like expand out on like what it thinks about the problem
like what it thinks about the problem
like what it thinks about the problem and what needs to happen before it
and what needs to happen before it
and what needs to happen before it actually gives you the answer. Right.
actually gives you the answer. Right.
actually gives you the answer. Right. Exactly.
Exactly.
Exactly. I think that's the whole point. So we
I think that's the whole point. So we
I think that's the whole point. So we could go do this, but this thing just
could go do this, but this thing just
could go do this, but this thing just allows the model to go have this in its
allows the model to go have this in its
allows the model to go have this in its training loop. Now the problem is in the
training loop. Now the problem is in the
training loop. Now the problem is in the basic training loop of what a model is
basic training loop of what a model is
basic training loop of what a model is doing, it's really just trained to draw
doing, it's really just trained to draw
doing, it's really just trained to draw attention from whatever it thinks is
attention from whatever it thinks is
attention from whatever it thinks is relevant. So if you just do
relevant. So if you just do
relevant. So if you just do this in the model generation loop, the
this in the model generation loop, the
this in the model generation loop, the model is really just drawing attention
model is really just drawing attention
model is really just drawing attention from anything that it thinks is
from anything that it thinks is
from anything that it thinks is relevant.
relevant.
relevant. I call this like standard generation or
I call this like standard generation or
I call this like standard generation or normal generation or something. Yeah.
normal generation or something. Yeah.
normal generation or something. Yeah. Yeah. The generation is the same. All
Yeah. The generation is the same. All
Yeah. The generation is the same. All I'm saying is what the model is trying
I'm saying is what the model is trying
I'm saying is what the model is trying to do is learn the difference between
to do is learn the difference between
to do is learn the difference between tokens between these two tokens. Yeah,
tokens between these two tokens. Yeah,
tokens between these two tokens. Yeah, have extra weight. The text, the actual
have extra weight. The text, the actual
have extra weight. The text, the actual tokens in here have no special meaning.
tokens in here have no special meaning.
tokens in here have no special meaning. It's just that this is a good marker for
It's just that this is a good marker for
It's just that this is a good marker for the model
the model
the model to know that everything in between has
to know that everything in between has
to know that everything in between has special weight and it should be
special weight and it should be
special weight and it should be considered a little bit more uh
considered a little bit more uh
considered a little bit more uh logically flowing. And it might even
logically flowing. And it might even
logically flowing. And it might even bias things at the bottom. I don't
bias things at the bottom. I don't
bias things at the bottom. I don't really know how the model works, but it
really know how the model works, but it
really know how the model works, but it you could reason that it could bias
you could reason that it could bias
you could reason that it could bias things at the bottom of the reasoning
things at the bottom of the reasoning
things at the bottom of the reasoning loop more than things at the top of the
loop more than things at the top of the
loop more than things at the top of the reasoning loop. Right. Right. And like
reasoning loop. Right. Right. And like
reasoning loop. Right. Right. And like the the old school way you would do this
the the old school way you would do this
the the old school way you would do this would basically be like you would you
would basically be like you would you
would basically be like you would you would call an LLM
would call an LLM
would call an LLM um and you would put in your input
um and you would put in your input
um and you would put in your input tokens and you would say like make a
tokens and you would say like make a
tokens and you would say like make a plan like think about this thing and
plan like think about this thing and
plan like think about this thing and tell me what you
tell me what you
tell me what you think and then you would put that in the
think and then you would put that in the
think and then you would put that in the LM and then it would output your like
LM and then it would output your like
LM and then it would output your like answer which was like okay here's the
answer which was like okay here's the
answer which was like okay here's the plan and then you would take that plan
plan and then you would take that plan
plan and then you would take that plan and you would pass it into another like
and you would pass it into another like
and you would pass it into another like either probably the same LLM but just
either probably the same LLM but just
either probably the same LLM but just like a fresh prompt.
like a fresh prompt.
like a fresh prompt. And then it would be like okay based on
And then it would be like okay based on
And then it would be like okay based on that plan here's the answer and the plan
that plan here's the answer and the plan
that plan here's the answer and the plan is something like you know do a complex
is something like you know do a complex
is something like you know do a complex math problem or generate a bunch of code
math problem or generate a bunch of code
math problem or generate a bunch of code or whatever it is right if you've used
or whatever it is right if you've used
or whatever it is right if you've used cursor or clots on it like you've seen
cursor or clots on it like you've seen
cursor or clots on it like you've seen it do this right exactly so like if I go
it do this right exactly so like if I go
it do this right exactly so like if I go over here
over here
over here um if I go over here in the above
um if I go over here in the above
um if I go over here in the above section decks
section decks
section decks in the wrong thinking so this is one way
in the wrong thinking so this is one way
in the wrong thinking so this is one way to go do that where it's still standard
to go do that where it's still standard
to go do that where it's still standard generation and I'm just taking advantage
generation and I'm just taking advantage
generation and I'm just taking advantage of the fact that I can force the model
of the fact that I can force the model
of the fact that I can force the model to generate these thinking
to generate these thinking
to generate these thinking tokens. The only difference is instead
tokens. The only difference is instead
tokens. The only difference is instead of the model like knowing what these
of the model like knowing what these
of the model like knowing what these thinking tokens are and having to infer
thinking tokens are and having to infer
thinking tokens are and having to infer that things between these are thinking,
that things between these are thinking,
that things between these are thinking, I can just train it in the training loop
I can just train it in the training loop
I can just train it in the training loop to know the difference.
to know the difference.
to know the difference. Yeah. Otherwise, it's just taking
Yeah. Otherwise, it's just taking
Yeah. Otherwise, it's just taking whatever its normal sort of like
whatever its normal sort of like
whatever its normal sort of like interpretation of thinking as just what
interpretation of thinking as just what
interpretation of thinking as just what is the meaning of that token in general,
is the meaning of that token in general,
is the meaning of that token in general, but not as a special token. Exactly.
but not as a special token. Exactly.
but not as a special token. Exactly. Exactly. That's it. So that's really all
Exactly. That's it. So that's really all
Exactly. That's it. So that's really all that's happening here is the model is
that's happening here is the model is
that's happening here is the model is somehow able to come up with
somehow able to come up with
somehow able to come up with understanding what a thinking model is.
understanding what a thinking model is.
understanding what a thinking model is. Um there's I think uh there's a question
Um there's I think uh there's a question
Um there's I think uh there's a question in the chat. Yeah. Which which elems are
in the chat. Yeah. Which which elems are
in the chat. Yeah. Which which elems are these reasoning tokens applicable to?
these reasoning tokens applicable to?
these reasoning tokens applicable to? Um so these reasoning tokens are u again
Um so these reasoning tokens are u again
Um so these reasoning tokens are u again this is like one possible implementation
this is like one possible implementation
this is like one possible implementation of how reasoning could work in. Um this
of how reasoning could work in. Um this
of how reasoning could work in. Um this there's a few other different ways that
there's a few other different ways that
there's a few other different ways that you could implement such a thing. Um for
you could implement such a thing. Um for
you could implement such a thing. Um for example the you could technically say
example the you could technically say
example the you could technically say that reasoning start is not required. I
that reasoning start is not required. I
that reasoning start is not required. I will only generate a reasoning end token
will only generate a reasoning end token
will only generate a reasoning end token nothing
nothing
nothing else. Uh you could use tool calling or
else. Uh you could use tool calling or
else. Uh you could use tool calling or something else as an implementation
something else as an implementation
something else as an implementation detail of how this works. But most have
detail of how this works. But most have
detail of how this works. But most have something of this akin of where reason
something of this akin of where reason
something of this akin of where reason starts. They need to have some de
starts. They need to have some de
starts. They need to have some de demarcation in the way that the LM
demarcation in the way that the LM
demarcation in the way that the LM generates tokens that tells you where it
generates tokens that tells you where it
generates tokens that tells you where it ends and where it starts. Yeah. So like
ends and where it starts. Yeah. So like
ends and where it starts. Yeah. So like the the tool calling one's really
the the tool calling one's really
the the tool calling one's really interesting. I want to I want to pause
interesting. I want to I want to pause
interesting. I want to I want to pause on that for a sec. So like you could
on that for a sec. So like you could
on that for a sec. So like you could have a function like send email and then
have a function like send email and then
have a function like send email and then you could have the parameters be
you could have the parameters be
you could have the parameters be something like uh you know oh let me
something like uh you know oh let me
something like uh you know oh let me make proper JSON here you know thought
process and that's a string and then you
process and that's a string and then you have email content right
have email content right
have email content right and so in this case if you ask the model
and so in this case if you ask the model
and so in this case if you ask the model to output those fields in that order
to output those fields in that order
to output those fields in that order it's going to tell you like oh here's
it's going to tell you like oh here's
it's going to tell you like oh here's what I was thinking about and then also
what I was thinking about and then also
what I was thinking about and then also here's the email. So you're kind of
here's the email. So you're kind of
here's the email. So you're kind of forcing it to output tokens about its
forcing it to output tokens about its
forcing it to output tokens about its thought process.
thought process.
thought process. Yes. But that is very much akin to like
Yes. But that is very much akin to like
Yes. But that is very much akin to like this option right over here. Exactly.
this option right over here. Exactly.
this option right over here. Exactly. Yeah. Same idea. Like people have been I
Yeah. Same idea. Like people have been I
Yeah. Same idea. Like people have been I think I think when function calling
think I think when function calling
think I think when function calling first came out in like April 2023,
first came out in like April 2023,
first came out in like April 2023, OpenAI had advice actually to put the
OpenAI had advice actually to put the
OpenAI had advice actually to put the first parameter of your function to be
first parameter of your function to be
first parameter of your function to be like thought or like thinking or like
like thought or like thinking or like
like thought or like thinking or like whatever it is. And I think I've seen
whatever it is. And I think I've seen
whatever it is. And I think I've seen like like the early lang chain function
like like the early lang chain function
like like the early lang chain function calling loops would actually do that.
calling loops would actually do that.
calling loops would actually do that. They would have it output the thought
They would have it output the thought
They would have it output the thought and then they would strip that out and
and then they would strip that out and
and then they would strip that out and print it to the console and then go run
print it to the console and then go run
print it to the console and then go run run the function that it output.
run the function that it output.
run the function that it output. Exactly. So, we'll talk about this in a
Exactly. So, we'll talk about this in a
Exactly. So, we'll talk about this in a few seconds. Um, but just to catch
few seconds. Um, but just to catch
few seconds. Um, but just to catch everyone else up. Um, oh, I'll leave
everyone else up. Um, oh, I'll leave
everyone else up. Um, oh, I'll leave that there. Um, do these two different
that there. Um, do these two different
that there. Um, do these two different approaches of how thinking works under
approaches of how thinking works under
approaches of how thinking works under the hood makes any questions about them
the hood makes any questions about them
the hood makes any questions about them so
far? I'll wait a couple seconds just to
far? I'll wait a couple seconds just to see if people are typing them out.
see if people are typing them out.
see if people are typing them out. Um, but if not, I think I want to move
Um, but if not, I think I want to move
Um, but if not, I think I want to move on to the next part that I think is
on to the next part that I think is
on to the next part that I think is going to be a lot more interesting.
going to be a lot more interesting.
going to be a lot more interesting. Yeah. Which is going to be more along
Yeah. Which is going to be more along
Yeah. Which is going to be more along the lines of how do we actually get
the lines of how do we actually get
the lines of how do we actually get models to do thought processes kind of
models to do thought processes kind of
models to do thought processes kind of akin to what you were saying? Uh, Dex.
akin to what you were saying? Uh, Dex.
akin to what you were saying? Uh, Dex. Yeah. What one thing I'd be one thing
Yeah. What one thing I'd be one thing
Yeah. What one thing I'd be one thing I'd be interested to try is like I have
I'd be interested to try is like I have
I'd be interested to try is like I have a couple like top of mind like really
a couple like top of mind like really
a couple like top of mind like really hard cipher queries like like text
hard cipher queries like like text
hard cipher queries like like text descriptions of queries and we can try
descriptions of queries and we can try
descriptions of queries and we can try and see if this thing can get it. We can
and see if this thing can get it. We can
and see if this thing can get it. We can drop in like switch the model to a much
drop in like switch the model to a much
drop in like switch the model to a much smarter model and see that that model
smarter model and see that that model
smarter model and see that that model can actually figure it out and then go
can actually figure it out and then go
can actually figure it out and then go back to see hey how can we pipeline boro
back to see hey how can we pipeline boro
back to see hey how can we pipeline boro mini to get it to get close to the sim
mini to get it to get close to the sim
mini to get it to get close to the sim same same same results. What do you
same same same results. What do you
same same same results. What do you think about that? All right cool idea.
think about that? All right cool idea.
think about that? All right cool idea. Um, so I'm going to refresh this. Let's
Um, so I'm going to refresh this. Let's
Um, so I'm going to refresh this. Let's ask something like tell me how many
ask something like tell me how many
ask something like tell me how many movies that Kiana
movies that Kiana
movies that Kiana Reeves and Alan Degenerous this might be
Reeves and Alan Degenerous this might be
Reeves and Alan Degenerous this might be zero are both in.
Okay. Yeah. So, I don't know if this
Okay. Yeah. So, I don't know if this query is wrong or what, but I don't
query is wrong or what, but I don't
query is wrong or what, but I don't know.
know.
know. Um, what's another what's another one
Um, what's another what's another one
Um, what's another what's another one that's hard to get right? Um, as it
that's hard to get right? Um, as it
that's hard to get right? Um, as it turns out, it's actually very hard to
turns out, it's actually very hard to
turns out, it's actually very hard to write. Um, uh, you can try the Kevin
write. Um, uh, you can try the Kevin
write. Um, uh, you can try the Kevin Bacon
Bacon
Bacon number's Kevin Bacon number.
Um, what's the definition of Kevin Bacon
Um, what's the definition of Kevin Bacon number?
number?
number? It's six degrees of Kevin
It's six degrees of Kevin
It's six degrees of Kevin Bacon. He's like, um, you can just ask
Bacon. He's like, um, you can just ask
Bacon. He's like, um, you can just ask it to do six degrees of play play six
it to do six degrees of play play six
it to do six degrees of play play six degrees of Kevin
degrees of Kevin
degrees of Kevin Bacon with K
right. Okay.
right. Okay. What
What
What happened? Just say try again.
happened? Just say try again.
happened? Just say try again. Let's see. I think this might be a back
Let's see. I think this might be a back
Let's see. I think this might be a back end problem.
end problem.
end problem. Uh,
okay. There you go.
okay. There you go. So as we saw I think the most
So as we saw I think the most
So as we saw I think the most interesting part here was that this kind
interesting part here was that this kind
interesting part here was that this kind of
of
of uh
uh
uh um this kind of has an issue where we
um this kind of has an issue where we
um this kind of has an issue where we was having a lot of variability coming
was having a lot of variability coming
was having a lot of variability coming into this. So the question becomes how
into this. So the question becomes how
into this. So the question becomes how could we make this better if we wanted
could we make this better if we wanted
could we make this better if we wanted to? Let's swap it out to 03 reasoning 03
to? Let's swap it out to 03 reasoning 03
to? Let's swap it out to 03 reasoning 03 mini. Uh what's the 03 model that you
mini. Uh what's the 03 model that you
mini. Uh what's the 03 model that you have? Uh I think you have 03 preview in
have? Uh I think you have 03 preview in
have? Uh I think you have 03 preview in here.
here.
here. Uh, let's use mini.
Uh, yeah, 03 mini. Okay. Oh, 03 mini. I
Uh, yeah, 03 mini. Okay. Oh, 03 mini. I think that's a reasoning model. So, we
think that's a reasoning model. So, we
think that's a reasoning model. So, we should just
Okay, that did a regen, right? Yeah.
Okay, that did a regen, right? Yeah. Okay,
Ah, lazy.
Ah, lazy. So one I mean firstly the model is going
So one I mean firstly the model is going
So one I mean firstly the model is going to get a lot slower. We all know this
to get a lot slower. We all know this
to get a lot slower. We all know this because it's going to be start
because it's going to be start
because it's going to be start thinking. Hey sorry people
um it started to go do this and it was
um it started to go do this and it was able to go do something that's kind of
able to go do something that's kind of
able to go do something that's kind of similar. But what will end up happening
similar. But what will end up happening
similar. But what will end up happening is that this model is going to be a
is that this model is going to be a
is that this model is going to be a little bit more um how do I describe it?
little bit more um how do I describe it?
little bit more um how do I describe it? A little bit more reliable on a lot more
A little bit more reliable on a lot more
A little bit more reliable on a lot more questions. So like for example right now
questions. So like for example right now
questions. So like for example right now we have to add a lot more context about
we have to add a lot more context about
we have to add a lot more context about what Kevin Bacon is. Just restart you
what Kevin Bacon is. Just restart you
what Kevin Bacon is. Just restart you start a new question say compute the
start a new question say compute the
start a new question say compute the Kevin Bacon number
for a particular actor uh for Kevin Spy
for a particular actor uh for Kevin Spy or uh yeah Kevin Spacy.
or uh yeah Kevin Spacy.
or uh yeah Kevin Spacy. Sure. And what this model will do is
Sure. And what this model will do is
Sure. And what this model will do is because it kind of knows what the Kevin
because it kind of knows what the Kevin
because it kind of knows what the Kevin Bacon number is will probably produce
Bacon number is will probably produce
Bacon number is will probably produce some of the answers of exactly what that
some of the answers of exactly what that
some of the answers of exactly what that is along the way.
is along the way.
is along the way. And it was all everybody's number is
And it was all everybody's number is
And it was all everybody's number is two. Okay, so let's do another one. What
two. Okay, so let's do another one. What
two. Okay, so let's do another one. What actors have a Kevin Bacon number five?
actors have a Kevin Bacon number five?
actors have a Kevin Bacon number five? Good question. Now, this is going to be
Good question. Now, this is going to be
Good question. Now, this is going to be a very interesting query,
a very interesting query,
a very interesting query, but I think what I want to start playing
but I think what I want to start playing
but I think what I want to start playing around with that, I'm going to ask for
around with that, I'm going to ask for
around with that, I'm going to ask for Yeah. Um Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Um,
uh, once it's done, there's also, I will
uh, once it's done, there's also, I will say there's a bunch of, um, if you go if
say there's a bunch of, um, if you go if
say there's a bunch of, um, if you go if you go to the database, I'll just show
you go to the database, I'll just show
you go to the database, I'll just show you as well. There, they have a bunch of
you as well. There, they have a bunch of
you as well. There, they have a bunch of interesting queries with good prompts
interesting queries with good prompts
interesting queries with good prompts that we could try as well. So, if you go
that we could try as well. So, if you go
that we could try as well. So, if you go to connect to the server and you do play
to connect to the server and you do play
to connect to the server and you do play this
this
this thing, there we go. Uh this gives you a
thing, there we go. Uh this gives you a
thing, there we go. Uh this gives you a bunch of HTML with like problems and
bunch of HTML with like problems and
bunch of HTML with like problems and things you can do. So we can put in some
things you can do. So we can put in some
things you can do. So we can put in some of these like really complica complex
of these like really complica complex
of these like really complica complex like chicardian distance things and we
like chicardian distance things and we
like chicardian distance things and we can ask it to like do this kind of
can ask it to like do this kind of
can ask it to like do this kind of stuff. But um anyways, yeah. You want to
stuff. But um anyways, yeah. You want to
stuff. But um anyways, yeah. You want to jump in the code? Yeah, I'm going to
jump in the code? Yeah, I'm going to
jump in the code? Yeah, I'm going to request remote control for participate.
request remote control for participate.
request remote control for participate. Yep. Cool. Uh let's talk about how we
Yep. Cool. Uh let's talk about how we
Yep. Cool. Uh let's talk about how we could if we wanted Oops, I'm still on
could if we wanted Oops, I'm still on
could if we wanted Oops, I'm still on drawing
drawing
drawing mode. Let's talk about how we could if
mode. Let's talk about how we could if
mode. Let's talk about how we could if we wanted take advantage. And I'm going
we wanted take advantage. And I'm going
we wanted take advantage. And I'm going to have to do no vim mode because I'm a
to have to do no vim mode because I'm a
to have to do no vim mode because I'm a flood. Uh if we want to take advantage
flood. Uh if we want to take advantage
flood. Uh if we want to take advantage of GPT40 mini and somehow turn this into
of GPT40 mini and somehow turn this into
of GPT40 mini and somehow turn this into a reasoning model. Well, the first thing
a reasoning model. Well, the first thing
a reasoning model. Well, the first thing we could do is we could just tell the
we could do is we could just tell the
we could do is we could just tell the model
um before
um before answering note what is useful and
answering note what is useful and
answering note what is useful and particularly hard.
example. Okay. And before we go into
example. Okay. And before we go into this, I kind of want to just walk
this, I kind of want to just walk
this, I kind of want to just walk through this without having to go and do
through this without having to go and do
through this without having to go and do the entire prompt the whole time. Um,
the entire prompt the whole time. Um,
the entire prompt the whole time. Um, can you do me a favor and paste the
can you do me a favor and paste the
can you do me a favor and paste the scheme? Oh, yeah. Let's get I'll get the
scheme? Oh, yeah. Let's get I'll get the
scheme? Oh, yeah. Let's get I'll get the scheme in there for you. Uh, one second.
scheme in there for you. Uh, one second.
scheme in there for you. Uh, one second. One second. Uh, let me just add the
One second. Uh, let me just add the
One second. Uh, let me just add the hashtag. So,
hashtag. So,
hashtag. So, cool. You can plug that. Yep.
Don't need the uh
Don't need the uh Yeah, let me just uh real quick.
Yeah, let me just uh real quick.
Yeah, let me just uh real quick. Yeah, we definitely don't need this.
Yeah, we definitely don't need this.
Yeah, we definitely don't need this. Cool. So, let's look at what the prompt
Cool. So, let's look at what the prompt
Cool. So, let's look at what the prompt ends up being like just so we can get a
ends up being like just so we can get a
ends up being like just so we can get a good feel for this.
good feel for this.
good feel for this. Um so a prompt has a massive input with
Um so a prompt has a massive input with
Um so a prompt has a massive input with the actual schema but then at the
the actual schema but then at the
the actual schema but then at the very at the very bottom what we do is we
very at the very bottom what we do is we
very at the very bottom what we do is we add in the user's messages and after the
add in the user's messages and after the
add in the user's messages and after the user's messages we tell the model what
user's messages we tell the model what
user's messages we tell the model what it should be doing. We tell it that it
it should be doing. We tell it that it
it should be doing. We tell it that it should be answering in one of these
should be answering in one of these
should be answering in one of these schemas but then before answering I
schemas but then before answering I
schemas but then before answering I actually wanted to go and note these
actually wanted to go and note these
actually wanted to go and note these things that are particularly hard.
things that are particularly hard.
things that are particularly hard. So, and now we'll say that the model
So, and now we'll say that the model
So, and now we'll say that the model will actually note what things are
will actually note what things are
will actually note what things are particularly hard and I'll start with a
particularly hard and I'll start with a
particularly hard and I'll start with a cipher and then I'll go ahead and go
cipher and then I'll go ahead and go
cipher and then I'll go ahead and go return it for us. So, I've in effect
return it for us. So, I've in effect
return it for us. So, I've in effect I've turned this model into a reasoning
I've turned this model into a reasoning
I've turned this model into a reasoning model without actually using any
model without actually using any
model without actually using any reasoning under the hood. If I Well,
reasoning under the hood. If I Well,
reasoning under the hood. If I Well, this is still 03 mini, right? Nope. Oh,
this is still 03 mini, right? Nope. Oh,
this is still 03 mini, right? Nope. Oh, you switch it. Okay, nice.
you switch it. Okay, nice.
you switch it. Okay, nice. Yeah. If I make this part go
away, now this part is no longer in the
away, now this part is no longer in the problem. The model is going to output
problem. The model is going to output
problem. The model is going to output just outputs the JSON. Exactly. So it's
just outputs the JSON. Exactly. So it's
just outputs the JSON. Exactly. So it's going to we there's an interesting
going to we there's an interesting
going to we there's an interesting balance that I'm able to strike which is
balance that I'm able to strike which is
balance that I'm able to strike which is I can turn an existing model into a
I can turn an existing model into a
I can turn an existing model into a reasoning model and make it go do things
reasoning model and make it go do things
reasoning model and make it go do things by telling it how to go do things. Now
by telling it how to go do things. Now
by telling it how to go do things. Now if I out I I think one technique that
if I out I I think one technique that
if I out I I think one technique that someone mentioned in the thing is I
someone mentioned in the thing is I
someone mentioned in the thing is I could tell the model to output thinking
could tell the model to output thinking
could tell the model to output thinking tags
tags
tags um and again this is
um and again this is
um and again this is uh
uh
uh notes and my notes and then go
notes and my notes and then go
notes and my notes and then go answer and if I go okay
answer and if I go okay
answer and if I go okay so here you can actually like experiment
so here you can actually like experiment
so here you can actually like experiment which like which which thinking token
which like which which thinking token
which like which which thinking token name is actually the best for for
name is actually the best for for
name is actually the best for for getting good results right and you can
getting good results right and you can
getting good results right and you can see that the model is actually not even
see that the model is actually not even
see that the model is actually not even outputting this and maybe it's cuz the
outputting this and maybe it's cuz the
outputting this and maybe it's cuz the word example is bad. So we can go play
word example is bad. So we can go play
word example is bad. So we can go play around with this and it's still not
around with this and it's still not
around with this and it's still not outputting this. It seems like it's a
outputting this. It seems like it's a
outputting this. It seems like it's a little bit easier for the model to just
little bit easier for the model to just
little bit easier for the model to just not have to think about this from like a
not have to think about this from like a
not have to think about this from like a notes perspective and just like answer
notes perspective and just like answer
notes perspective and just like answer with this as a point as a as a list and
with this as a point as a as a list and
with this as a point as a as a list and one thing to note here is it's actually
one thing to note here is it's actually
one thing to note here is it's actually really bene now what I could have done
really bene now what I could have done
really bene now what I could have done is one of the and I want to comment what
is one of the and I want to comment what
is one of the and I want to comment what I was noting earlier is I could have
I was noting earlier is I could have
I was noting earlier is I could have added a thing into here a little bit
added a thing into here a little bit
added a thing into here a little bit better.
better.
better. It's called
It's called
It's called like Oops. Yeah. Let's skip the action
like Oops. Yeah. Let's skip the action
like Oops. Yeah. Let's skip the action first. Yeah.
first. Yeah.
first. Yeah. Reasoning
string. I can add this into both of
string. I can add this into both of these instead of doing
these instead of doing
these instead of doing this. And now when I get answer, I
this. And now when I get answer, I
this. And now when I get answer, I actually get like a little answer, a
actually get like a little answer, a
actually get like a little answer, a reasoning behind what the model is
reasoning behind what the model is
reasoning behind what the model is trying to do. This was the function
trying to do. This was the function
trying to do. This was the function calling version of what we're This is
calling version of what we're This is
calling version of what we're This is the function calling version of getting
the function calling version of getting
the function calling version of getting reasoning out. And this has a couple of
reasoning out. And this has a couple of
reasoning out. And this has a couple of benefits. But in reality, the this
benefits. But in reality, the this
benefits. But in reality, the this actually has if I make a more
actually has if I make a more
actually has if I make a more complicated query like
complicated query like
complicated query like what
reads like what is RE's most uh
reads like what is RE's most uh reasoning number. You can see that like
reasoning number. You can see that like
reasoning number. You can see that like this is feels a lot lot more constrained
this is feels a lot lot more constrained
this is feels a lot lot more constrained for the model. So let's try and let's
for the model. So let's try and let's
for the model. So let's try and let's try and not do this and instead use a
try and not do this and instead use a
try and not do this and instead use a more previous thing. Um over here when
more previous thing. Um over here when
more previous thing. Um over here when you what do you mean by constrained for
you what do you mean by constrained for
you what do you mean by constrained for the model? You mean you're just like
the model? You mean you're just like
the model? You mean you're just like forcing it to output it in a specific
forcing it to output it in a specific
forcing it to output it in a specific format instead of like what it's used
format instead of like what it's used
format instead of like what it's used to? This reasoning is kind of
to? This reasoning is kind of
to? This reasoning is kind of um it's kind of like um really uh what's
um it's kind of like um really uh what's
um it's kind of like um really uh what's the word I'm looking
the word I'm looking
the word I'm looking for? It's really it's not how models
for? It's really it's not how models
for? It's really it's not how models write. It's not like the training data
write. It's not like the training data
write. It's not like the training data set is not going to have large blocks of
set is not going to have large blocks of
set is not going to have large blocks of useful text in JSON objects. They're
useful text in JSON objects. They're
useful text in JSON objects. They're going to be in plain text before the
going to be in plain text before the
going to be in plain text before the JSON object. Exactly. Yeah. Like now
JSON object. Exactly. Yeah. Like now
JSON object. Exactly. Yeah. Like now what we can do is now we can see this
what we can do is now we can see this
what we can do is now we can see this for
for
for example where now when it's outputting
example where now when it's outputting
example where now when it's outputting the reasoning if I just can I make this
the reasoning if I just can I make this
the reasoning if I just can I make this bigger really fast? Sorry. Yeah. Yeah. I
bigger really fast? Sorry. Yeah. Yeah. I
bigger really fast? Sorry. Yeah. Yeah. I can also zoom out. Oh yeah, that's
can also zoom out. Oh yeah, that's
can also zoom out. Oh yeah, that's great. Okay. Now if I actually look at
great. Okay. Now if I actually look at
great. Okay. Now if I actually look at just the difference between these two
just the difference between these two
just the difference between these two things to determine Kevin I need to
things to determine Kevin I need to
things to determine Kevin I need to perform a giraffe query that connects to
perform a giraffe query that connects to
perform a giraffe query that connects to reeves to the actors and movies through
reeves to the actors and movies through
reeves to the actors and movies through this and it's trying to do this but if I
this and it's trying to do this but if I
this and it's trying to do this but if I look over here it's actually able to
look over here it's actually able to
look over here it's actually able to just output this a little bit more now
just output this a little bit more now
just output this a little bit more now and it's able to go understand what uh
and it's able to go understand what uh
and it's able to go understand what uh the text here is in a little bit more
the text here is in a little bit more
the text here is in a little bit more well and it's cool sorry what's really
well and it's cool sorry what's really
well and it's cool sorry what's really dope about this that I'm just noticing
dope about this that I'm just noticing
dope about this that I'm just noticing is like it's outputting the cipher and
is like it's outputting the cipher and
is like it's outputting the cipher and then it's use and it's doing that in
then it's use and it's doing that in
then it's use and it's doing that in whatever format it wants and then it's
whatever format it wants and then it's
whatever format it wants and then it's converting that into a JSON format. So
converting that into a JSON format. So
converting that into a JSON format. So it's like writing cipher in the way that
it's like writing cipher in the way that
it's like writing cipher in the way that like most of the training set will be
like most of the training set will be
like most of the training set will be written as as like cipher in markdown
written as as like cipher in markdown
written as as like cipher in markdown explaining [ __ ] and then it's going to
explaining [ __ ] and then it's going to
explaining [ __ ] and then it's going to put that into the actual structured
put that into the actual structured
put that into the actual structured object. Exactly. Now you might say that
object. Exactly. Now you might say that
object. Exactly. Now you might say that when you display a graph query to a user
when you display a graph query to a user
when you display a graph query to a user you might still want to include
you might still want to include
you might still want to include reasoning because there's multiple
reasoning because there's multiple
reasoning because there's multiple impacts of how you can leverage using
impacts of how you can leverage using
impacts of how you can leverage using reasoning. One is to make the model
reasoning. One is to make the model
reasoning. One is to make the model better and this technique of outputting
better and this technique of outputting
better and this technique of outputting the uh reasoning in the context actually
the uh reasoning in the context actually
the uh reasoning in the context actually just makes the model better. Now there's
just makes the model better. Now there's
just makes the model better. Now there's another way that we might want to do
another way that we might want to do
another way that we might want to do this which is I might want to show the
this which is I might want to show the
this which is I might want to show the user exactly what's going on behind the
user exactly what's going on behind the
user exactly what's going on behind the scenes. So if I want to go do that then
scenes. So if I want to go do that then
scenes. So if I want to go do that then I can add reasoning over
I can add reasoning over
I can add reasoning over here description and of like the like
here description and of like the like
here description and of like the like post post reason kind of thing. Exactly.
post post reason kind of thing. Exactly.
post post reason kind of thing. Exactly. And what I want to hear I want to write
And what I want to hear I want to write
And what I want to hear I want to write here is like a short
here is like a short
here is like a short message to the user
message to the user
message to the user uh
uh
uh summarizing the notes.
summarizing the notes.
summarizing the notes. So when I go run this I still get
So when I go run this I still get
So when I go run this I still get reasoning as I
reasoning as I
reasoning as I want and then I can give the re a
want and then I can give the re a
want and then I can give the re a shorter version of the reasoning to uh
shorter version of the reasoning to uh
shorter version of the reasoning to uh the end user. So I can kind of man
the end user. So I can kind of man
the end user. So I can kind of man reasoning is now becoming a thing that I
reasoning is now becoming a thing that I
reasoning is now becoming a thing that I can choose what I'm doing with rather
can choose what I'm doing with rather
can choose what I'm doing with rather than a thing that I have to go do in a
than a thing that I have to go do in a
than a thing that I have to go do in a specific way. So I think the blend of
specific way. So I think the blend of
specific way. So I think the blend of what reasoning is it's very overloaded
what reasoning is it's very overloaded
what reasoning is it's very overloaded for a lot of users.
for a lot of users.
for a lot of users. Go ahead. It's like the the same thing
Go ahead. It's like the the same thing
Go ahead. It's like the the same thing we did last week where it's like okay
we did last week where it's like okay
we did last week where it's like okay you have one version of this that goes
you have one version of this that goes
you have one version of this that goes into the embedding, one version that
into the embedding, one version that
into the embedding, one version that goes into the LM and one version that is
goes into the LM and one version that is
goes into the LM and one version that is read by deterministic code and those are
read by deterministic code and those are
read by deterministic code and those are all three different things. And so now
all three different things. And so now
all three different things. And so now you're splitting out like what's the LM
you're splitting out like what's the LM
you're splitting out like what's the LM reasoning versus what's a thing that's
reasoning versus what's a thing that's
reasoning versus what's a thing that's valuable for me to show in the UI for
valuable for me to show in the UI for
valuable for me to show in the UI for the user. Exactly. And the fact that we
the user. Exactly. And the fact that we
the user. Exactly. And the fact that we happen to call it all reasoning is a
happen to call it all reasoning is a
happen to call it all reasoning is a totally different concept. Um it's just
totally different concept. Um it's just
totally different concept. Um it's just like we're humans are bad at naming uh
like we're humans are bad at naming uh
like we're humans are bad at naming uh and we're using the same name to do two
and we're using the same name to do two
and we're using the same name to do two different things which normally you
different things which normally you
different things which normally you wouldn't do but you can just see how
wouldn't do but you can just see how
wouldn't do but you can just see how much better the reasoning is now. So in
much better the reasoning is now. So in
much better the reasoning is now. So in some effect by nature of me telling the
some effect by nature of me telling the
some effect by nature of me telling the model that I actually have to go and
model that I actually have to go and
model that I actually have to go and display reasoning to the user I actually
display reasoning to the user I actually
display reasoning to the user I actually got a better reasoning process right
got a better reasoning process right
got a better reasoning process right over here as well.
over here as well.
over here as well. Hey uh could you clarify if this is the
Hey uh could you clarify if this is the
Hey uh could you clarify if this is the same as chain of thought.
same as chain of thought.
same as chain of thought. Uh it's it's very similar to chain of
Uh it's it's very similar to chain of
Uh it's it's very similar to chain of thought. I think it's a little bit more
thought. I think it's a little bit more
thought. I think it's a little bit more free form
free form
free form uh than chain of thought. I think um you
uh than chain of thought. I think um you
uh than chain of thought. I think um you can I think when I I think when people
can I think when I I think when people
can I think when I I think when people first introduced chain of thought it was
first introduced chain of thought it was
first introduced chain of thought it was like a very structured approach to how
like a very structured approach to how
like a very structured approach to how you approach a problem. It's a subset of
you approach a problem. It's a subset of
you approach a problem. It's a subset of reasoning. Reasoning is a bigger group.
reasoning. Reasoning is a bigger group.
reasoning. Reasoning is a bigger group. Um because reasoning doesn't necessarily
Um because reasoning doesn't necessarily
Um because reasoning doesn't necessarily mean like I'm going to chain of thought
mean like I'm going to chain of thought
mean like I'm going to chain of thought to me I think when the paper came out
to me I think when the paper came out
to me I think when the paper came out implied that there's a sequence of
implied that there's a sequence of
implied that there's a sequence of things that I will go
things that I will go
things that I will go do here. the model happened to believe
do here. the model happened to believe
do here. the model happened to believe that a sequence made
that a sequence made
that a sequence made sense. But if I change my test case to
sense. But if I change my test case to
sense. But if I change my test case to to something else where it's like uh
to something else where it's like uh
to something else where it's like uh what it's going to read is bacon number.
what it's going to read is bacon number.
what it's going to read is bacon number. It's
It's
It's like how do I make
cookies and the model's actually going
cookies and the model's actually going to reply and the answer might be like I
to reply and the answer might be like I
to reply and the answer might be like I actually don't want the model to reply
actually don't want the model to reply
actually don't want the model to reply here. Um I can actually inject that into
here. Um I can actually inject that into
here. Um I can actually inject that into the reasoning over here. Uh it's over
the reasoning over here. Uh it's over
the reasoning over here. Uh it's over here before entering. Know what is hard?
here before entering. Know what is hard?
here before entering. Know what is hard? Um know what is it
Um know what is it
Um know what is it hard or things that indicate the user is
hard or things that indicate the user is
hard or things that indicate the user is not
using. Let me try and find my way out of
using. Let me try and find my way out of this. trying to help the ether out
as let's add another class.
as let's add another class. Uh,
let me get added to the return types.
let me get added to the return types. Yeah.
Um, so I can go do something like this
Um, so I can go do something like this and give an action like to the user of
and give an action like to the user of
and give an action like to the user of like not relevant.
like not relevant.
like not relevant. It's interesting that it didn't print
It's interesting that it didn't print
It's interesting that it didn't print out all of the text though. It's just
out all of the text though. It's just
out all of the text though. It's just going straight to JSON again. So I think
going straight to JSON again. So I think
going straight to JSON again. So I think it's more about what the model's able to
it's more about what the model's able to
it's more about what the model's able to do. So chain of thought is again very
do. So chain of thought is again very
do. So chain of thought is again very prescribed in what it's going to go do.
prescribed in what it's going to go do.
prescribed in what it's going to go do. Yeah. Because when it does something in
Yeah. Because when it does something in
Yeah. Because when it does something in chain of thought, you're kind of forcing
chain of thought, you're kind of forcing
chain of thought, you're kind of forcing it to go down that line of reasoning.
it to go down that line of reasoning.
it to go down that line of reasoning. What I'm doing here, I specifically ask
What I'm doing here, I specifically ask
What I'm doing here, I specifically ask the model to note what is useful and
the model to note what is useful and
the model to note what is useful and particularly hard or things that
particularly hard or things that
particularly hard or things that indicate the user is not using the
indicate the user is not using the
indicate the user is not using the schema. But if the model feels that it's
schema. But if the model feels that it's
schema. But if the model feels that it's a very direct query, then it doesn't
a very direct query, then it doesn't
a very direct query, then it doesn't really have to go and go make that line.
really have to go and go make that line.
really have to go and go make that line. It doesn't have to generate those
It doesn't have to generate those
It doesn't have to generate those tokens. It's easier for it to just
tokens. It's easier for it to just
tokens. It's easier for it to just generate the final output. And that's
generate the final output. And that's
generate the final output. And that's where I think reasoning is a slightly
where I think reasoning is a slightly
where I think reasoning is a slightly bigger superset of chain of thought.
bigger superset of chain of thought.
bigger superset of chain of thought. Chain of thought is almost prescriptive.
Chain of thought is almost prescriptive.
Chain of thought is almost prescriptive. If it doesn't do chain of thought, that
If it doesn't do chain of thought, that
If it doesn't do chain of thought, that is bad because I added a chain of
is bad because I added a chain of
is bad because I added a chain of thought prompt. Reasoning, I think, was
thought prompt. Reasoning, I think, was
thought prompt. Reasoning, I think, was invented with this premise. And that's
invented with this premise. And that's
invented with this premise. And that's what I think Openi did really amazingly.
what I think Openi did really amazingly.
what I think Openi did really amazingly. this premise of elasticity on how much
this premise of elasticity on how much
this premise of elasticity on how much reasoning I'm allowed to do, how much
reasoning I'm allowed to do, how much
reasoning I'm allowed to do, how much reasoning I don't want to do. And in
reasoning I don't want to do. And in
reasoning I don't want to do. And in this case, the model is choosing none.
this case, the model is choosing none.
this case, the model is choosing none. And in the chain of thought world, it's
And in the chain of thought world, it's
And in the chain of thought world, it's almost going to have to it it almost has
almost going to have to it it almost has
almost going to have to it it almost has to do chain of thought. Does that answer
to do chain of thought. Does that answer
to do chain of thought. Does that answer the question about the nuance there,
the question about the nuance there,
the question about the nuance there, Pashant? But I think they're very very
Pashant? But I think they're very very
Pashant? But I think they're very very similar.
similar.
similar. Yeah. Uh I think it does. I mean, I'm
Yeah. Uh I think it does. I mean, I'm
Yeah. Uh I think it does. I mean, I'm still trying to wrap my head around like
still trying to wrap my head around like
still trying to wrap my head around like the model choice here. So if you had an
the model choice here. So if you had an
the model choice here. So if you had an actual reasoning model, it treats the
actual reasoning model, it treats the
actual reasoning model, it treats the prompt completely differently. So you're
prompt completely differently. So you're
prompt completely differently. So you're not talking about that form of reasoning
not talking about that form of reasoning
not talking about that form of reasoning here. This this reasoning here is purely
here. This this reasoning here is purely
here. This this reasoning here is purely related to the model's internal thinking
related to the model's internal thinking
related to the model's internal thinking process. Exactly. And if you go back to
process. Exactly. And if you go back to
process. Exactly. And if you go back to the other thing that's the you want to
the other thing that's the you want to
the other thing that's the you want to go back to the UI. No, no, not the UI,
go back to the UI. No, no, not the UI,
go back to the UI. No, no, not the UI, the Excalibur.
the Excalibur.
the Excalibur. Yeah. Yeah. So in the reasoning model
Yeah. Yeah. So in the reasoning model
Yeah. Yeah. So in the reasoning model what ends up happening is a model that's
what ends up happening is a model that's
what ends up happening is a model that's fine-tuned with reasoning is forced to
fine-tuned with reasoning is forced to
fine-tuned with reasoning is forced to generate a reasoning start token. So it
generate a reasoning start token. So it
generate a reasoning start token. So it has to out it has to do reasoning to
has to out it has to do reasoning to
has to out it has to do reasoning to text and now after it does the reasoning
text and now after it does the reasoning
text and now after it does the reasoning text then only eventually it'll output
text then only eventually it'll output
text then only eventually it'll output the reasoning end token then it can
the reasoning end token then it can
the reasoning end token then it can generate the regular text that I need
generate the regular text that I need
generate the regular text that I need for the actual u
response. But in a chain of thought
response. But in a chain of thought world there's no such thing as reasoning
world there's no such thing as reasoning
world there's no such thing as reasoning text and reasoning end. But I I almost
text and reasoning end. But I I almost
text and reasoning end. But I I almost am chain of thought is more like this.
am chain of thought is more like this.
am chain of thought is more like this. If the model doesn't generate thinking
If the model doesn't generate thinking
If the model doesn't generate thinking text as a part of its response, it is
text as a part of its response, it is
text as a part of its response, it is bad.
bad.
bad. Reasoning all right because it doesn't
Reasoning all right because it doesn't
Reasoning all right because it doesn't abide by my instructions of what I told
abide by my instructions of what I told
abide by my instructions of what I told it to do. Reasoning is a little bit I
it to do. Reasoning is a little bit I
it to do. Reasoning is a little bit I think the whole goal of reasoning is
think the whole goal of reasoning is
think the whole goal of reasoning is elasticity. So the amount of tokens that
elasticity. So the amount of tokens that
elasticity. So the amount of tokens that the model generates in here could be
the model generates in here could be
the model generates in here could be zero, it could be 500, it could be a
zero, it could be 500, it could be a
zero, it could be 500, it could be a thousand. And that's why OpenAI even
thousand. And that's why OpenAI even
thousand. And that's why OpenAI even gives you a choice of how many reasoning
gives you a choice of how many reasoning
gives you a choice of how many reasoning tokens you're allowed to generate,
tokens you're allowed to generate,
tokens you're allowed to generate, right? How hard do you want it to think?
right? How hard do you want it to think?
right? How hard do you want it to think? Right. Well, how hard do you want it to
Right. Well, how hard do you want it to
Right. Well, how hard do you want it to think is one concept, but it's really
think is one concept, but it's really
think is one concept, but it's really around like how many tokens are you
around like how many tokens are you
around like how many tokens are you allowed to generate in this block? Yep.
allowed to generate in this block? Yep.
allowed to generate in this block? Yep. Right. Um, and that's kind of associated
Right. Um, and that's kind of associated
Right. Um, and that's kind of associated with thinking, but think about what that
with thinking, but think about what that
with thinking, but think about what that does to the model. It actually it could
does to the model. It actually it could
does to the model. It actually it could technically terminate
midthought because open is saying that
midthought because open is saying that there's no more tokens that you can
there's no more tokens that you can
there's no more tokens that you can generate after this because they can't
generate after this because they can't
generate after this because they can't predict the future tokens. They can only
predict the future tokens. They can only
predict the future tokens. They can only generate tokens up until now. It's kind
generate tokens up until now. It's kind
generate tokens up until now. It's kind of like the conraint constraint
of like the conraint constraint
of like the conraint constraint generation thing, right? When you force
generation thing, right? When you force
generation thing, right? When you force the model to only generate tokens that
the model to only generate tokens that
the model to only generate tokens that are valid JSON, you kind of you kind of
are valid JSON, you kind of you kind of
are valid JSON, you kind of you kind of screw up with it trying to write like
screw up with it trying to write like
screw up with it trying to write like whatever like in the way that it's been
whatever like in the way that it's been
whatever like in the way that it's been trained to write things. Yeah. But the
trained to write things. Yeah. But the
trained to write things. Yeah. But the only caveat here is that the tokens here
only caveat here is that the tokens here
only caveat here is that the tokens here that it generates in the reasoning text
that it generates in the reasoning text
that it generates in the reasoning text could have a huge
could have a huge
could have a huge impact if I were them. Uh you could have
impact if I were them. Uh you could have
impact if I were them. Uh you could have a huge impact in how these next tokens
a huge impact in how these next tokens
a huge impact in how these next tokens are generated in a little bit more
are generated in a little bit more
are generated in a little bit more nuanced way than it would normally be
nuanced way than it would normally be
nuanced way than it would normally be generated. So if you if you're doing
generated. So if you if you're doing
generated. So if you if you're doing this, there's no special things that
this, there's no special things that
this, there's no special things that things in the thinking tag are getting.
things in the thinking tag are getting.
things in the thinking tag are getting. It's giving no special
It's giving no special
It's giving no special weight. But you could imagine that in
weight. But you could imagine that in
weight. But you could imagine that in the training loop, the model has learned
the training loop, the model has learned
the training loop, the model has learned that things between the reasoning block
that things between the reasoning block
that things between the reasoning block are actually extra useful. So there's
are actually extra useful. So there's
are actually extra useful. So there's one advantage to thinking models that
one advantage to thinking models that
one advantage to thinking models that can't really be replicated with any
can't really be replicated with any
can't really be replicated with any prompt engineering technique.
prompt engineering technique.
prompt engineering technique. Now the problem with thinking models is
Now the problem with thinking models is
Now the problem with thinking models is you will they cost a lot more because
you will they cost a lot more because
you will they cost a lot more because fundamentally you are asking the model
fundamentally you are asking the model
fundamentally you are asking the model to generate special tokens in here that
to generate special tokens in here that
to generate special tokens in here that are just going to be a lot more tokens
are just going to be a lot more tokens
are just going to be a lot more tokens right it's just what this whole thing
right it's just what this whole thing
right it's just what this whole thing about like inference time test time
about like inference time test time
about like inference time test time compute is just like oh if the model
compute is just like oh if the model
compute is just like oh if the model generates more tokens before it actually
generates more tokens before it actually
generates more tokens before it actually puts its answer in you get a better
puts its answer in you get a better
puts its answer in you get a better answer uh and so people realize like oh
answer uh and so people realize like oh
answer uh and so people realize like oh we don't need way smarter models we just
we don't need way smarter models we just
we don't need way smarter models we just need them to generate more tokens before
need them to generate more tokens before
need them to generate more tokens before they answer and so now it's like okay
they answer and so now it's like okay
they answer and so now it's like okay cool So we need more GPUs and we need
cool So we need more GPUs and we need
cool So we need more GPUs and we need more inference and we need more compute.
more inference and we need more compute.
more inference and we need more compute. Exactly. And the real thought process if
Exactly. And the real thought process if
Exactly. And the real thought process if you go back to our to our other thing
you go back to our to our other thing
you go back to our to our other thing the code the code. Yeah. The real
the code the code. Yeah. The real
the code the code. Yeah. The real thought process that I'm really having
thought process that I'm really having
thought process that I'm really having when I make these decisions of do I just
when I make these decisions of do I just
when I make these decisions of do I just swap out for a reasoning model or not?
swap out for a reasoning model or not?
swap out for a reasoning model or not? It comes along the lines of the
It comes along the lines of the
It comes along the lines of the following. when I decide to go use this
following. when I decide to go use this
following. when I decide to go use this thing and swap out a reason model, what
thing and swap out a reason model, what
thing and swap out a reason model, what I'm really saying is I want to spend
I'm really saying is I want to spend
I'm really saying is I want to spend less time on this prompt side of it and
less time on this prompt side of it and
less time on this prompt side of it and I wanted to mostly just work out of the
I wanted to mostly just work out of the
I wanted to mostly just work out of the box. So, I today am willing to spend
box. So, I today am willing to spend
box. So, I today am willing to spend more money. So, I spend less time
more money. So, I spend less time
more money. So, I spend less time prompting and the model spends more time
prompting and the model spends more time
prompting and the model spends more time prompting. It's a monthly equation and a
prompting. It's a monthly equation and a
prompting. It's a monthly equation and a time equation. I want to spend less time
time equation. I want to spend less time
time equation. I want to spend less time and and I want to spend more money in
and and I want to spend more money in
and and I want to spend more money in favor of time to get a better slightly
favor of time to get a better slightly
favor of time to get a better slightly better response. Now, you go ahead. Go
better response. Now, you go ahead. Go
better response. Now, you go ahead. Go ahead. I we we have 10 minutes left and
ahead. I we we have 10 minutes left and
ahead. I we we have 10 minutes left and I wanted to kind of propose just like um
I wanted to kind of propose just like um
I wanted to kind of propose just like um a couple interesting things I' I'd be
a couple interesting things I' I'd be
a couple interesting things I' I'd be interested to mess with um in the time
interested to mess with um in the time
interested to mess with um in the time we have left. Cool. Uh go for it. Um so
we have left. Cool. Uh go for it. Um so
we have left. Cool. Uh go for it. Um so I have you seen debate prompting? Have
I have you seen debate prompting? Have
I have you seen debate prompting? Have you seen this paper? Yes. Yes. Yeah. I
you seen this paper? Yes. Yes. Yeah. I
you seen this paper? Yes. Yes. Yeah. I was interested to see like hey if we if
was interested to see like hey if we if
was interested to see like hey if we if we kind of take out um how do I get this
we kind of take out um how do I get this
we kind of take out um how do I get this stupid annotation thing off? So like
stupid annotation thing off? So like
stupid annotation thing off? So like Yeah. Okay. So, if we change this back
Yeah. Okay. So, if we change this back
Yeah. Okay. So, if we change this back to like, you know, which actors have a
to like, you know, which actors have a
to like, you know, which actors have a Kevin
Kevin
Kevin Bacon number of five, which was the
Bacon number of five, which was the
Bacon number of five, which was the thing that like the model just like
thing that like the model just like
thing that like the model just like completely like floundered on the last
completely like floundered on the last
completely like floundered on the last time. Um, and can we put in some debate
time. Um, and can we put in some debate
time. Um, and can we put in some debate prompting where it's like we ask it like
prompting where it's like we ask it like
prompting where it's like we ask it like initial
initial
initial reasoning problems with initial
reasoning problems with initial
reasoning problems with initial reasoning?
reasoning?
reasoning? Um, you know, well, we could we could do
Um, you know, well, we could we could do
Um, you know, well, we could we could do this in the main prompt. We don't even
this in the main prompt. We don't even
this in the main prompt. We don't even have to do this in the structure.
have to do this in the structure.
have to do this in the structure. Um, okay. Let's try this and then we'll
Um, okay. Let's try this and then we'll
Um, okay. Let's try this and then we'll we'll put in the main prompt as well.
we'll put in the main prompt as well.
we'll put in the main prompt as well. Um, or you want to do that? Yeah. Yeah,
Um, or you want to do that? Yeah. Yeah,
Um, or you want to do that? Yeah. Yeah, let's play the main. It'll probably work
let's play the main. It'll probably work
let's play the main. It'll probably work out a little better. Okay, cool. So this
out a little better. Okay, cool. So this
out a little better. Okay, cool. So this is like initial
is like initial
is like initial reasoning, problems with initial
reasoning, problems with initial
reasoning, problems with initial reasoning, improved reasoning,
reasoning, improved reasoning,
reasoning, improved reasoning, uh final
uh final
uh final reasoning, and then the schema. Right?
reasoning, and then the schema. Right?
reasoning, and then the schema. Right? So now there's a do you want to put this
So now there's a do you want to put this
So now there's a do you want to put this down here or do you want to leave it
down here or do you want to leave it
down here or do you want to leave it like that? That's fine. That's fine.
like that? That's fine. That's fine.
like that? That's fine. That's fine. That's good. That's good. Okay. So
That's good. That's good. Okay. So
That's good. That's good. Okay. So there's a actually you can run this and
there's a actually you can run this and
there's a actually you can run this and I'll tell you a couple things that h
I'll tell you a couple things that h
I'll tell you a couple things that h happen off the bat. So Okay. So the
happen off the bat. So Okay. So the
happen off the bat. So Okay. So the first thing that you'll notice is you're
first thing that you'll notice is you're
first thing that you'll notice is you're you're getting very short reasoning
you're getting very short reasoning
you're getting very short reasoning responses. Yeah. So and the reason for
responses. Yeah. So and the reason for
responses. Yeah. So and the reason for that is because
that is because
that is because because we put it on bulleted list. It's
because we put it on bulleted list. It's
because we put it on bulleted list. It's because No, no, no. It's because How do
because No, no, no. It's because How do
because No, no, no. It's because How do I type? Can I Can you give me the typing
I type? Can I Can you give me the typing
I type? Can I Can you give me the typing thingy? Oh yeah, there's a way to turn
thingy? Oh yeah, there's a way to turn
thingy? Oh yeah, there's a way to turn off Vim mode. Hold on. Does anyone
off Vim mode. Hold on. Does anyone
off Vim mode. Hold on. Does anyone remember which one it is? It's okay.
remember which one it is? It's okay.
remember which one it is? It's okay. Just give me normal VI mode. I just need
Just give me normal VI mode. I just need
Just give me normal VI mode. I just need typing. Uh I I type like a plug. Yeah,
typing. Uh I I type like a plug. Yeah,
typing. Uh I I type like a plug. Yeah, that's fine.
that's fine.
that's fine. You have you have other uh you have
You have you have other uh you have
You have you have other uh you have other you want to put this in like a
other you want to put this in like a
other you want to put this in like a markdown header just just by nature
markdown header just just by nature
markdown header just just by nature putting it in
putting it in
putting it in um putting into here. Yeah. Make a huge
um putting into here. Yeah. Make a huge
um putting into here. Yeah. Make a huge difference in how things do
difference in how things do
difference in how things do and we can even do something like we can
and we can even do something like we can
and we can even do something like we can even tell it it's like I want to
even tell it it's like I want to
even tell it it's like I want to generate a cipher. Oh yeah. I was going
generate a cipher. Oh yeah. I was going
generate a cipher. Oh yeah. I was going that was the next thing I was going to
that was the next thing I was going to
that was the next thing I was going to suggest is like you know one of these
suggest is like you know one of these
suggest is like you know one of these headers is like propose cipher cipher
headers is like propose cipher cipher
headers is like propose cipher cipher query and then problems with query and
query and then problems with query and
query and then problems with query and then
then
then and
exactly and now we can actually go do it
exactly and now we can actually go do it like over here and we can actually kind
like over here and we can actually kind
like over here and we can actually kind of guide the model and the kind of
of guide the model and the kind of
of guide the model and the kind of reason that we wanted to do and again
reason that we wanted to do and again
reason that we wanted to do and again it's more about like
it's more about like
it's more about like it's more about how we're guiding the
it's more about how we're guiding the
it's more about how we're guiding the model really more than anything else and
model really more than anything else and
model really more than anything else and it turns out if I know what kind of
it turns out if I know what kind of
it turns out if I know what kind of approach I'm building and I'm not
approach I'm building and I'm not
approach I'm building and I'm not actually building like
actually building like
actually building like um if I'm not actually building a uh
um if I'm not actually building a uh
um if I'm not actually building a uh sorry if I'm not building an an
sorry if I'm not building an an
sorry if I'm not building an an everything chatbot like open AI and I
everything chatbot like open AI and I
everything chatbot like open AI and I know building specifically a thing that
know building specifically a thing that
know building specifically a thing that talks about cipher queries and uh rag
talks about cipher queries and uh rag
talks about cipher queries and uh rag pipeline cypher queries on like a graph
pipeline cypher queries on like a graph
pipeline cypher queries on like a graph database then I'm actually able to guide
database then I'm actually able to guide
database then I'm actually able to guide the structure of my technique a lot more
the structure of my technique a lot more
the structure of my technique a lot more if I don't know this then I want to go
if I don't know this then I want to go
if I don't know this then I want to go fall back to a more free form approach
fall back to a more free form approach
fall back to a more free form approach or like you know you have a router at
or like you know you have a router at
or like you know you have a router at the top that is like oh is this about
the top that is like oh is this about
the top that is like oh is this about Neo forj movies and then route it to
Neo forj movies and then route it to
Neo forj movies and then route it to this prompt to handle that. Exactly.
this prompt to handle that. Exactly.
this prompt to handle that. Exactly. Yes, you can do it that way as well. So
Yes, you can do it that way as well. So
Yes, you can do it that way as well. So kind of build our reliability up over
kind of build our reliability up over
kind of build our reliability up over time but it's all a trade-off on this
time but it's all a trade-off on this
time but it's all a trade-off on this elasticity thing that I was talking
elasticity thing that I was talking
elasticity thing that I was talking about which is like look at the very
about which is like look at the very
about which is like look at the very beginning I can have one prompt that I
beginning I can have one prompt that I
beginning I can have one prompt that I just throw at a mega model and it has to
just throw at a mega model and it has to
just throw at a mega model and it has to do everything and go figure it out. The
do everything and go figure it out. The
do everything and go figure it out. The problem with this onep prompt approach
problem with this onep prompt approach
problem with this onep prompt approach that I go right where I use and oh can
that I go right where I use and oh can
that I go right where I use and oh can you you I can just do it on the black
you you I can just do it on the black
you you I can just do it on the black screen it's fine. Okay. The problem with
screen it's fine. Okay. The problem with
screen it's fine. Okay. The problem with this one prompt approach that I will
this one prompt approach that I will
this one prompt approach that I will often end up with is that my
often end up with is that my
often end up with is that my distribution will end up looking
distribution will end up looking
distribution will end up looking something like this. It's a very like
something like this. It's a very like
something like this. It's a very like it's a very like normal distribution
it's a very like normal distribution
it's a very like normal distribution that's very quite spread out. I get a
that's very quite spread out. I get a
that's very quite spread out. I get a lot of variation in my responses. Now,
lot of variation in my responses. Now,
lot of variation in my responses. Now, what Dex just suggested was I could have
what Dex just suggested was I could have
what Dex just suggested was I could have a route where I build a specific prompt
a route where I build a specific prompt
a route where I build a specific prompt that is really really good at cipher
that is really really good at cipher
that is really really good at cipher queries and another it's going to be
queries and another it's going to be
queries and another it's going to be trash at making cookie recipes though.
trash at making cookie recipes though.
trash at making cookie recipes though. Yeah, it's going to be trash at making
Yeah, it's going to be trash at making
Yeah, it's going to be trash at making cookie. Exactly. Um, where I could go
cookie. Exactly. Um, where I could go
cookie. Exactly. Um, where I could go ahead and like say something that this
ahead and like say something that this
ahead and like say something that this is like about like an intent
is like about like an intent
is like about like an intent router and then oops uh cipher
router and then oops uh cipher
router and then oops uh cipher prompt and then I can have I can still
prompt and then I can have I can still
prompt and then I can have I can still do my my everything prompt over here.
do my my everything prompt over here.
do my my everything prompt over here. Yeah. Everything else. Right. Exactly.
Yeah. Everything else. Right. Exactly.
Yeah. Everything else. Right. Exactly. So now what what ends up happening Oh my
So now what what ends up happening Oh my
So now what what ends up happening Oh my god, this so hard. What ends up
god, this so hard. What ends up
god, this so hard. What ends up happening is my distribution for these
happening is my distribution for these
happening is my distribution for these prompts will get slightly better. This
prompts will get slightly better. This
prompts will get slightly better. This prompt should technically have a pretty
prompt should technically have a pretty
prompt should technically have a pretty high distribution with low spread where
high distribution with low spread where
high distribution with low spread where I can accurately get their intent
I can accurately get their intent
I can accurately get their intent classification. Yep. And then what I aim
classification. Yep. And then what I aim
classification. Yep. And then what I aim for is I want this prompt to have a
for is I want this prompt to have a
for is I want this prompt to have a really really high distribution on
really really high distribution on
really really high distribution on cipher queries and kind of perform worse
cipher queries and kind of perform worse
cipher queries and kind of perform worse on everything else at the benefit of
on everything else at the benefit of
on everything else at the benefit of outperforming on cipher queries. And
outperforming on cipher queries. And
outperforming on cipher queries. And then I can actually have another one
then I can actually have another one
then I can actually have another one that says that it's going to work again.
that says that it's going to work again.
that says that it's going to work again. It's going to have a high it's going to
It's going to have a high it's going to
It's going to have a high it's going to have a high spread and low accuracy on
have a high spread and low accuracy on
have a high spread and low accuracy on everything else. I can slowly compose
everything else. I can slowly compose
everything else. I can slowly compose these systems together to build a
these systems together to build a
these systems together to build a slightly more accurate system. And this
slightly more accurate system. And this
slightly more accurate system. And this is where I can still throw a reasoning
is where I can still throw a reasoning
is where I can still throw a reasoning model at this part of my pipeline, but
model at this part of my pipeline, but
model at this part of my pipeline, but have more specific reasoning on this
have more specific reasoning on this
have more specific reasoning on this side of my pipeline. So I can slowly
side of my pipeline. So I can slowly
side of my pipeline. So I can slowly build the system that I actually want to
build the system that I actually want to
build the system that I actually want to build with more guidance along the way.
build with more guidance along the way.
build with more guidance along the way. So it's the blend of the two. And what's
So it's the blend of the two. And what's
So it's the blend of the two. And what's amazing about this technique is there's
amazing about this technique is there's
amazing about this technique is there's nothing here that actually says I can't
nothing here that actually says I can't
nothing here that actually says I can't actually do this with 03 mini. Like I
actually do this with 03 mini. Like I
actually do this with 03 mini. Like I can kind of blend. I can let a reasoning
can kind of blend. I can let a reasoning
can kind of blend. I can let a reasoning model do its thing and on top of that I
model do its thing and on top of that I
model do its thing and on top of that I can also leverage non the non-reasoning
can also leverage non the non-reasoning
can also leverage non the non-reasoning approach to go ahead and think about
approach to go ahead and think about
approach to go ahead and think about this as well and once it's done it will
this as well and once it's done it will
this as well and once it's done it will go do it. I wish we thinking tokens. We
go do it. I wish we thinking tokens. We
go do it. I wish we thinking tokens. We really should.
really should.
really should. Um yes I would like that too if you'll
Um yes I would like that too if you'll
Um yes I would like that too if you'll spit out the thinking tokens. Yeah, if
spit out the thinking tokens. Yeah, if
spit out the thinking tokens. Yeah, if you do the curl, you can see both. And
you do the curl, you can see both. And
you do the curl, you can see both. And thinking tokens come, it's so crazy
thinking tokens come, it's so crazy
thinking tokens come, it's so crazy because like the thinking tokens just
because like the thinking tokens just
because like the thinking tokens just get spewed out raw and then it spits out
get spewed out raw and then it spits out
get spewed out raw and then it spits out JSON at the end, which is actually kind
JSON at the end, which is actually kind
JSON at the end, which is actually kind of bambly when you think about it. Yeah.
of bambly when you think about it. Yeah.
of bambly when you think about it. Yeah. Um I want to try one more thing um in
Um I want to try one more thing um in
Um I want to try one more thing um in the five minutes we have left on the
the five minutes we have left on the
the five minutes we have left on the clock and then we can um hold for time
clock and then we can um hold for time
clock and then we can um hold for time for questions at the end. Does that
for questions at the end. Does that
for questions at the end. Does that work? Let's do it. Um I want to take
work? Let's do it. Um I want to take
work? Let's do it. Um I want to take these three things and uh put them in
these three things and uh put them in
these three things and uh put them in the response.
the response.
the response. um do it.
um do it.
um do it. So, and then I want to spit them out to
So, and then I want to spit them out to
So, and then I want to spit them out to the user in the UI because like this
the user in the UI because like this
the user in the UI because like this becomes kind of a magical kind of AI app
becomes kind of a magical kind of AI app
becomes kind of a magical kind of AI app building experience as
building experience as
building experience as well. Um so,
uh and just be like a short summary of
uh and just be like a short summary of initial message, a shorter a short
initial message, a shorter a short
initial message, a shorter a short summary to display to the user.
Yeah, it's specific that we want to talk
Yeah, it's specific that we want to talk about displaying to the user because we
about displaying to the user because we
about displaying to the user because we don't want to bias the actual generation
don't want to bias the actual generation
don't want to bias the actual generation token that's going to go generate.
token that's going to go generate.
token that's going to go generate. Um, cool. Um, sick. And then in our
Um, cool. Um, sick. And then in our
Um, cool. Um, sick. And then in our actual server code, like the fact that
actual server code, like the fact that
actual server code, like the fact that we have kind of built this agent at
we have kind of built this agent at
we have kind of built this agent at hawk, we can do some really interesting
hawk, we can do some really interesting
hawk, we can do some really interesting things and like kind of take the outputs
things and like kind of take the outputs
things and like kind of take the outputs of our fancy prompting and throw it
of our fancy prompting and throw it
of our fancy prompting and throw it through everything else. Um, I added
through everything else. Um, I added
through everything else. Um, I added another one which is called not
another one which is called not
another one which is called not relevant. Can you delete that? That's
relevant. Can you delete that? That's
relevant. Can you delete that? That's why this uh Oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
why this uh Oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
why this uh Oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Um on line 39. Yeah. We'll just get rid
Um on line 39. Yeah. We'll just get rid
Um on line 39. Yeah. We'll just get rid of this.
of this.
of this. Yep. Chat doesn't work. That's why.
Yep. Chat doesn't work. That's why.
Yep. Chat doesn't work. That's why. Yeah. Um I love that JavaScript. I'm
Yeah. Um I love that JavaScript. I'm
Yeah. Um I love that JavaScript. I'm actually going to
um cool. and then completion the send a
um cool. and then completion the send a reasoning event. Yeah.
And then on the front end we can
And then on the front end we can actually try to display this
um ah where is our app app.ts page app.
um ah where is our app app.ts page app. Yeah components. Here we go. Um,
nice. This is going to be a little bit
nice. This is going to be a little bit janky, but let's see. Let's see how this
janky, but let's see. Let's see how this
janky, but let's see. Let's see how this looks.
looks.
looks. Um, or this is live coding. I've never
Um, or this is live coding. I've never
Um, or this is live coding. I've never tried this before. Oh, you're on 03
tried this before. Oh, you're on 03
tried this before. Oh, you're on 03 Mini. Can you get Oh, whatever. Uh,
Mini. Can you get Oh, whatever. Uh,
Mini. Can you get Oh, whatever. Uh, sure. Love the GT40 mini so it's faster.
sure. Love the GT40 mini so it's faster.
sure. Love the GT40 mini so it's faster. Yeah, let's go to 40 mini. I don't have
Yeah, let's go to 40 mini. I don't have
Yeah, let's go to 40 mini. I don't have time. No, we don't have time for that
time. No, we don't have time for that
time. No, we don't have time for that crap. Yeah.
crap. Yeah.
crap. Yeah. [Music]
[Music]
[Music] Um, let's go
Um, let's go
Um, let's go here. Let's
um, do a simple one and then we'll do a
um, do a simple one and then we'll do a really hard one. Yeah.
It didn't show our
It didn't show our reasoning. This is the fun part of live
reasoning. This is the fun part of live
reasoning. This is the fun part of live coding.
coding.
coding. Um, did you see what's going on there?
Um, did you see what's going on there?
Um, did you see what's going on there? Um, you might have to restart the app.
Um, you might have to restart the app.
Um, you might have to restart the app. Just restart the app really fast.
Also, this is just absolutely wrong. Um,
Also, this is just absolutely wrong. Um, okay.
okay.
okay. How many movies is
How many movies is
How many movies is uh Patrick sees and we'll start with a
uh Patrick sees and we'll start with a
uh Patrick sees and we'll start with a simple one.
Um do you render the reasoning object?
Um do you render the reasoning object? Uh I think we're trying to. Let's see.
Uh I think we're trying to. Let's see.
Uh I think we're trying to. Let's see. It's also not getting added to the
It's also not getting added to the
It's also not getting added to the messages stream here.
Okay. Um, you should just see on the
Okay. Um, you should just see on the back end as you're setting it
up. Okay, so this definitely came
up. Okay, so this definitely came out.
Um, we we'll time box this to like two
Um, we we'll time box this to like two more minutes. If we can't get it
more minutes. If we can't get it
more minutes. If we can't get it working, we'll we'll flip to questions
working, we'll we'll flip to questions
working, we'll we'll flip to questions or people want to start asking
or people want to start asking
or people want to start asking answering. Well, let's see if we can get
answering. Well, let's see if we can get
answering. Well, let's see if we can get this working.
No, this one is working. And then what's
No, this one is working. And then what's the event name that you sent it as? Uh
the event name that you sent it as? Uh
the event name that you sent it as? Uh reasoning.
reasoning.
reasoning. Yeah. And then just double check that
Yeah. And then just double check that
Yeah. And then just double check that you're actually receiving it as that
you're actually receiving it as that
you're actually receiving it as that event in your thing.
So event reasoning event graph query.
So event reasoning event graph query. Okay, so we did get a reasoning event.
Okay, so we did get a reasoning event.
Okay, so we did get a reasoning event. It's just like a UI bug. Yeah. Oh, see
It's just like a UI bug. Yeah. Oh, see
It's just like a UI bug. Yeah. Oh, see Reasoning
Reasoning
Reasoning message. Um,
message. Um,
message. Um, oh, you have to set messages.
oh, you have to set messages.
oh, you have to set messages. Go up to the top and you just miss one
Go up to the top and you just miss one
Go up to the top and you just miss one line after that. After reasoning
line after that. After reasoning
line after that. After reasoning message, just enter. Oh, yeah. Here we
message, just enter. Oh, yeah. Here we
message, just enter. Oh, yeah. Here we go. Great. There you go.
Uh, it didn't do the query. It won't do
Uh, it didn't do the query. It won't do it again because it has the answer.
it again because it has the answer.
it again because it has the answer. Yeah. uh in the message context. Yeah.
Yeah. There we go. So, you could style
Yeah. There we go. So, you could style this however you wanted. Um
this however you wanted. Um
this however you wanted. Um um uh I'd love for questions that people
um uh I'd love for questions that people
um uh I'd love for questions that people have if they want to type into reason
have if they want to type into reason
have if they want to type into reason models. Otherwise, I have a few other
models. Otherwise, I have a few other
models. Otherwise, I have a few other notes that I think might be worth it to
notes that I think might be worth it to
notes that I think might be worth it to talk about, but uh questions first.
I think I posted mine which is like what
I think I posted mine which is like what are the like ideas we can like condense
are the like ideas we can like condense
are the like ideas we can like condense from all of this because I know we had
from all of this because I know we had
from all of this because I know we had like things thrown in different
like things thrown in different
like things thrown in different directions but what would you say is the
directions but what would you say is the
directions but what would you say is the biggest takeaway? I think the biggest
biggest takeaway? I think the biggest
biggest takeaway? I think the biggest takeaway is really about time management
takeaway is really about time management
takeaway is really about time management of your engineering team is the biggest
of your engineering team is the biggest
of your engineering team is the biggest thing that I think about which is if you
thing that I think about which is if you
thing that I think about which is if you really want to ship something really
really want to ship something really
really want to ship something really really fast just throw an 03 model let
really fast just throw an 03 model let
really fast just throw an 03 model let it do its reasoning and you basically
it do its reasoning and you basically
it do its reasoning and you basically save time and you get the generation you
save time and you get the generation you
save time and you get the generation you want out on average this will be better
want out on average this will be better
want out on average this will be better just like using GPT40 on average will be
just like using GPT40 on average will be
just like using GPT40 on average will be better than GP40 mini on average a
better than GP40 mini on average a
better than GP40 mini on average a reasoning model will have a slightly
reasoning model will have a slightly
reasoning model will have a slightly better
better
better curve then of like like if I talk about
curve then of like like if I talk about
curve then of like like if I talk about accuracy versus varian A reasoning model
accuracy versus varian A reasoning model
accuracy versus varian A reasoning model will just be slightly less like this
will just be slightly less like this
will just be slightly less like this will if this is 040
will if this is 040
will if this is 040 uh then a reasoning model will be
uh then a reasoning model will be
uh then a reasoning model will be slightly le slightly better uh than than
slightly le slightly better uh than than
slightly le slightly better uh than than 40. Oh yes, thank you. That's I'll
40. Oh yes, thank you. That's I'll
40. Oh yes, thank you. That's I'll remove that for posterity. Um just I
remove that for posterity. Um just I
remove that for posterity. Um just I want it to be in the in the whiteboard
want it to be in the in the whiteboard
want it to be in the in the whiteboard for when we do the recap. I'll draw it
for when we do the recap. I'll draw it
for when we do the recap. I'll draw it on here. Um the reason model will
on here. Um the reason model will
on here. Um the reason model will basically just be like slightly um
basically just be like slightly um
basically just be like slightly um slightly better like the reason like
slightly better like the reason like
slightly better like the reason like this. So the correlary here is like if
this. So the correlary here is like if
this. So the correlary here is like if you need performance and speed and
you need performance and speed and
you need performance and speed and things like this, then you can go into
things like this, then you can go into
things like this, then you can go into engineering your own version of this.
engineering your own version of this.
engineering your own version of this. Right. Exactly. Then Exactly. So if you
Right. Exactly. Then Exactly. So if you
Right. Exactly. Then Exactly. So if you need better speed, you need better
need better speed, you need better
need better speed, you need better performance, you need better choice,
performance, you need better choice,
performance, you need better choice, then you can go ahead and go down the
then you can go ahead and go down the
then you can go ahead and go down the direction of actually picking the
direction of actually picking the
direction of actually picking the reasoning model of your choice. And or
reasoning model of your choice. And or
reasoning model of your choice. And or like if you need to run models on prem
like if you need to run models on prem
like if you need to run models on prem and you can't run deepseeek R1 or
and you can't run deepseeek R1 or
and you can't run deepseeek R1 or whatever and you can only run little
whatever and you can only run little
whatever and you can only run little llama models because you're at the edge
llama models because you're at the edge
llama models because you're at the edge or something. Exactly. And then the
or something. Exactly. And then the
or something. Exactly. And then the other thing you want to note is that
other thing you want to note is that
other thing you want to note is that like De said, not every model will
like De said, not every model will
like De said, not every model will support reasoning. So this is how you
support reasoning. So this is how you
support reasoning. So this is how you can leverage almost any model to go get
can leverage almost any model to go get
can leverage almost any model to go get reasoning out of it. Um, and really
reasoning out of it. Um, and really
reasoning out of it. Um, and really spending a little bit of time on what
spending a little bit of time on what
spending a little bit of time on what the reasoning that you want the model to
the reasoning that you want the model to
the reasoning that you want the model to generate is specifically with like the
generate is specifically with like the
generate is specifically with like the guided prompts that we showed earlier
guided prompts that we showed earlier
guided prompts that we showed earlier can improve your accuracy of evening
can improve your accuracy of evening
can improve your accuracy of evening reasoning models because free form
reasoning models because free form
reasoning models because free form reasoning as good as it is just going to
reasoning as good as it is just going to
reasoning as good as it is just going to be worse than guided reasoning if you
be worse than guided reasoning if you
be worse than guided reasoning if you know the domain you're operating in.
know the domain you're operating in.
know the domain you're operating in. Yeah. Right. So like if and that's the
Yeah. Right. So like if and that's the
Yeah. Right. So like if and that's the example of like asking it to actually
example of like asking it to actually
example of like asking it to actually like hey when you're reasoning output a
like hey when you're reasoning output a
like hey when you're reasoning output a cipher query and then review it and then
cipher query and then review it and then
cipher query and then review it and then output another one like there's no way
output another one like there's no way
output another one like there's no way to prompt a thinking model to do this
to prompt a thinking model to do this
to prompt a thinking model to do this other than like by asking it to do this
other than like by asking it to do this
other than like by asking it to do this basically like it's not going to come up
basically like it's not going to come up
basically like it's not going to come up with this structure probably. Yeah. And
with this structure probably. Yeah. And
with this structure probably. Yeah. And this structure might be good it might be
this structure might be good it might be
this structure might be good it might be bad. Obviously this is going to make it
bad. Obviously this is going to make it
bad. Obviously this is going to make it way worse for generating cookie recipes.
way worse for generating cookie recipes.
way worse for generating cookie recipes. Um, so don't do that. Uh, if you're if
Um, so don't do that. Uh, if you're if
Um, so don't do that. Uh, if you're if you need it to generate cookie recipes
you need it to generate cookie recipes
you need it to generate cookie recipes and this, but if you know that it
and this, but if you know that it
and this, but if you know that it doesn't have to do this, then it can um
doesn't have to do this, then it can um
doesn't have to do this, then it can um it can do something kind of I think you
it can do something kind of I think you
it can do something kind of I think you can get way better results.
can get way better results.
can get way better results. Yeah. See, it's like just gave up and
Yeah. See, it's like just gave up and
Yeah. See, it's like just gave up and said I can't do cookies because of how
said I can't do cookies because of how
said I can't do cookies because of how like intense its prompt was.
Dex and Weber, I have a question here.
Dex and Weber, I have a question here. So I understand for
So I understand for
So I understand for the for the normal models we have done
the for the normal models we have done
the for the normal models we have done some kind of prompt engineering where it
some kind of prompt engineering where it
some kind of prompt engineering where it is where we are asking it to reason over
is where we are asking it to reason over
is where we are asking it to reason over create a cipher then reason over it. Is
create a cipher then reason over it. Is
create a cipher then reason over it. Is it the same thing like splitting it into
it the same thing like splitting it into
it the same thing like splitting it into two maybe actor and checker kind of
two maybe actor and checker kind of
two maybe actor and checker kind of thing? One is acting then creating a
thing? One is acting then creating a
thing? One is acting then creating a loop between these two and refining it.
loop between these two and refining it.
loop between these two and refining it. Is that same or what is the difference?
Is that same or what is the difference?
Is that same or what is the difference? The only thing network curves that's a
The only thing network curves that's a
The only thing network curves that's a slightly different thing. Um because the
slightly different thing. Um because the
slightly different thing. Um because the way that that is working is
way that that is working is
way that that is working is um I'm going to go in solid draw and
um I'm going to go in solid draw and
um I'm going to go in solid draw and just draw what that ends up looking
just draw what that ends up looking
just draw what that ends up looking like. D I'm going to draw at the bottom.
like. D I'm going to draw at the bottom.
like. D I'm going to draw at the bottom. Yep. I'm here. I'm following you. Um so
Yep. I'm here. I'm following you. Um so
Yep. I'm here. I'm following you. Um so what that ends up looking like is this.
what that ends up looking like is this.
what that ends up looking like is this. So you're going to have a model go
So you're going to have a model go
So you're going to have a model go generate some let's say you have like
generate some let's say you have like
generate some let's say you have like some question by a
some question by a
some question by a user. I don't know why it's green. Um a
user. I don't know why it's green. Um a
user. I don't know why it's green. Um a user will ask a question. Then what
user will ask a question. Then what
user will ask a question. Then what you're doing is you're having the model
you're doing is you're having the model
you're doing is you're having the model go generate some um some
go generate some um some
go generate some um some response. Then what you're doing is
response. Then what you're doing is
response. Then what you're doing is you're having another user then you're
you're having another user then you're
you're having another user then you're having another model like do like do
having another model like do like do
having another model like do like do like like a
like like a
like like a checker response. And this is like the
checker response. And this is like the
checker response. And this is like the actor response. This is what you're
actor response. This is what you're
actor response. This is what you're talking about. This is like LM is judge,
talking about. This is like LM is judge,
talking about. This is like LM is judge, right? It's like, hey, review the
right? It's like, hey, review the
right? It's like, hey, review the question and the answer and see if it
question and the answer and see if it
question and the answer and see if it makes sense kind of thing, right? And
makes sense kind of thing, right? And
makes sense kind of thing, right? And then you kind of do this and like an
then you kind of do this and like an
then you kind of do this and like an iteration loop. Now, the thing that
iteration loop. Now, the thing that
iteration loop. Now, the thing that people don't realize when they do this
people don't realize when they do this
people don't realize when they do this is that your costs here are actually
is that your costs here are actually
is that your costs here are actually exponential. So, the first time you call
exponential. So, the first time you call
exponential. So, the first time you call the active response, your cost is just a
the active response, your cost is just a
the active response, your cost is just a question. When in order to generate the
question. When in order to generate the
question. When in order to generate the uh and I'll make this red so it's a
uh and I'll make this red so it's a
uh and I'll make this red so it's a little bit more clear. In order to
little bit more clear. In order to
little bit more clear. In order to generate the checker response, your cost
generate the checker response, your cost
generate the checker response, your cost is the question plus the
is the question plus the
is the question plus the checker plus uh uh plus the sorry
checker plus uh uh plus the sorry
checker plus uh uh plus the sorry question plus the actor. Yep. In order
question plus the actor. Yep. In order
question plus the actor. Yep. In order to generate this next one, it's question
to generate this next one, it's question
to generate this next one, it's question plus act
plus act
plus act actor plus checker again. So just to do
actor plus checker again. So just to do
actor plus checker again. So just to do like um just to do like a two-step
like um just to do like a two-step
like um just to do like a two-step process, you're passing the question
process, you're passing the question
process, you're passing the question three times, you're passing the actor
three times, you're passing the actor
three times, you're passing the actor twice.
twice.
twice. So your costs boil up exponentially
So your costs boil up exponentially
So your costs boil up exponentially really fast with this approach and if
really fast with this approach and if
really fast with this approach and if you're able to do it in line in the same
you're able to do it in line in the same
you're able to do it in line in the same prompt now your cost is basically just
prompt now your cost is basically just
prompt now your cost is basically just once for the question the actor checker
once for the question the actor checker
once for the question the actor checker actor response like the thing Dex showed
actor response like the thing Dex showed
actor response like the thing Dex showed in the in the code that he generated
in the in the code that he generated
in the in the code that he generated with the cipher query that is a single
with the cipher query that is a single
with the cipher query that is a single cost for all these things but isn't
cost for all these things but isn't
cost for all these things but isn't sorry isn't every token here like every
sorry isn't every token here like every
sorry isn't every token here like every every token that it's emitting you're
every token that it's emitting you're
every token that it's emitting you're still reprocessing the entire thing. So
still reprocessing the entire thing. So
still reprocessing the entire thing. So is this just like a context caching kind
is this just like a context caching kind
is this just like a context caching kind of thing we're taking advantage of
of thing we're taking advantage of
of thing we're taking advantage of models? Yeah, there's an optimization
models? Yeah, there's an optimization
models? Yeah, there's an optimization loop that allows them to not price you
loop that allows them to not price you
loop that allows them to not price you for that every single time, right?
for that every single time, right?
for that every single time, right? You're not rerunning them into a new
You're not rerunning them into a new
You're not rerunning them into a new request. You're just open pricing you is
request. You're just open pricing you is
request. You're just open pricing you is only for the new tokens that you're
only for the new tokens that you're
only for the new tokens that you're generating. If you go back to the other
generating. If you go back to the other
generating. If you go back to the other thing, yeah, now OpenAI is pricing you
thing, yeah, now OpenAI is pricing you
thing, yeah, now OpenAI is pricing you in a way where it's like the question is
in a way where it's like the question is
in a way where it's like the question is being priced three different times here
being priced three different times here
being priced three different times here because they're all separate requests to
because they're all separate requests to
because they're all separate requests to an LLM and they're treated as separate
an LLM and they're treated as separate
an LLM and they're treated as separate and it's like re reloading all the Yeah.
and it's like re reloading all the Yeah.
and it's like re reloading all the Yeah. Okay. Exactly. Does that make sense uh
Okay. Exactly. Does that make sense uh
Okay. Exactly. Does that make sense uh for the person that asked the question?
for the person that asked the question?
for the person that asked the question? Yeah. Yep. It does. Perfect. So, there's
Yeah. Yep. It does. Perfect. So, there's
Yeah. Yep. It does. Perfect. So, there's a benefit of basically cost, accuracy,
a benefit of basically cost, accuracy,
a benefit of basically cost, accuracy, and latency. In general, with this loop,
and latency. In general, with this loop,
and latency. In general, with this loop, you can get a little bit more control,
you can get a little bit more control,
you can get a little bit more control, but your cost will be a lot more and
but your cost will be a lot more and
but your cost will be a lot more and your latency will be a lot more. If
your latency will be a lot more. If
your latency will be a lot more. If you're able to do it in a single system,
you're able to do it in a single system,
you're able to do it in a single system, you might as well.
Great question. I love that question. I
Great question. I love that question. I hadn't thought about it this way, but
hadn't thought about it this way, but
hadn't thought about it this way, but that makes a ton of sense. Um, other
that makes a ton of sense. Um, other
that makes a ton of sense. Um, other other key other question also vibe. Does
other key other question also vibe. Does
other key other question also vibe. Does that does this capture all the key
that does this capture all the key
that does this capture all the key takeaways? like basically like time
takeaways? like basically like time
takeaways? like basically like time management versus co cost management and
management versus co cost management and
management versus co cost management and like being able to basically do really
like being able to basically do really
like being able to basically do really specific guided reasoning better than a
specific guided reasoning better than a
specific guided reasoning better than a generic model that's just trying to like
generic model that's just trying to like
generic model that's just trying to like spew a lot of nonsense before it
spew a lot of nonsense before it
spew a lot of nonsense before it answers. Yeah. And then one thing to
answers. Yeah. And then one thing to
answers. Yeah. And then one thing to note remember is that I showed that you
note remember is that I showed that you
note remember is that I showed that you can always use the combination of a
can always use the combination of a
can always use the combination of a reasoning model with guided reasoning as
reasoning model with guided reasoning as
reasoning model with guided reasoning as well.
We have one more question over here.
We have one more question over here. Um while asking LLM I can be wrong about
Um while asking LLM I can be wrong about
Um while asking LLM I can be wrong about many names. Sorry I'm I'm I'm not into
many names. Sorry I'm I'm I'm not into
many names. Sorry I'm I'm I'm not into movies. I don't know any of the names
movies. I don't know any of the names
movies. I don't know any of the names but I saw you writing caves or something
but I saw you writing caves or something
but I saw you writing caves or something reenu keys or some something like that.
reenu keys or some something like that.
reenu keys or some something like that. U if it if it's a wrong typing from the
U if it if it's a wrong typing from the
U if it if it's a wrong typing from the user do we actually go and check or is
user do we actually go and check or is
user do we actually go and check or is it like LLM correcting on behalf of us
it like LLM correcting on behalf of us
it like LLM correcting on behalf of us first and then generating cipher? How is
first and then generating cipher? How is
first and then generating cipher? How is it working? There's a really interesting
it working? There's a really interesting
it working? There's a really interesting blog post that I want to write about
blog post that I want to write about
blog post that I want to write about this which is how LM are just amazing
this which is how LM are just amazing
this which is how LM are just amazing spell checkers. Um
spell checkers. Um
spell checkers. Um oftentime if you go back to the code I
oftentime if you go back to the code I
oftentime if you go back to the code I think it's just easier to show in a
think it's just easier to show in a
think it's just easier to show in a demo.
demo.
demo. I understood that point I guess but uh
I understood that point I guess but uh
I understood that point I guess but uh think of it in in con uh in perspective
think of it in in con uh in perspective
think of it in in con uh in perspective of organizational data for example
of organizational data for example
of organizational data for example employee database right LM has no idea
employee database right LM has no idea
employee database right LM has no idea about it. So if I create a knowledge
about it. So if I create a knowledge
about it. So if I create a knowledge base let's say skill database of every
base let's say skill database of every
base let's say skill database of every employee and I'm I'm just asking that uh
employee and I'm I'm just asking that uh
employee and I'm I'm just asking that uh graph to give me answer about how many
graph to give me answer about how many
graph to give me answer about how many are you know skilled on
are you know skilled on
are you know skilled on BML right and then I say someone uh I
BML right and then I say someone uh I
BML right and then I say someone uh I give it a I give it a name basically and
give it a I give it a name basically and
give it a I give it a name basically and I want to get back all the skills of
I want to get back all the skills of
I want to get back all the skills of that particular employee from the graph.
that particular employee from the graph.
that particular employee from the graph. So how does it work? Can you go to the
So how does it work? Can you go to the
So how does it work? Can you go to the can you go to the
can you go to the
can you go to the uh codebase? I want to show a couple
uh codebase? I want to show a couple
uh codebase? I want to show a couple examples because I think it's going to
examples because I think it's going to
examples because I think it's going to be easier to talk about this with code
be easier to talk about this with code
be easier to talk about this with code because I think what is how can I get
because I think what is how can I get
because I think what is how can I get the model to reason about something in
the model to reason about something in
the model to reason about something in the case of it like being really unique.
the case of it like being really unique.
the case of it like being really unique. So it turns out because LM are really
So it turns out because LM are really
So it turns out because LM are really really good spell checkers. They will
really good spell checkers. They will
really good spell checkers. They will they will not abide by you. And I'm
they will not abide by you. And I'm
they will not abide by you. And I'm going to use like very simple examples
going to use like very simple examples
going to use like very simple examples to make this a point of how you could go
to make this a point of how you could go
to make this a point of how you could go do this. So let's say I'm I'm looking at
do this. So let's say I'm I'm looking at
do this. So let's say I'm I'm looking at a resume thing. I spelled name wrong.
a resume thing. I spelled name wrong.
a resume thing. I spelled name wrong. it is going to be virtually impossible
it is going to be virtually impossible
it is going to be virtually impossible for me to get the model to spit out
for me to get the model to spit out
for me to get the model to spit out NAE. It is going to be really, really,
NAE. It is going to be really, really,
NAE. It is going to be really, really, really hard. So, if an employes name
really hard. So, if an employes name
really hard. So, if an employes name just has a totally different misspelling
just has a totally different misspelling
just has a totally different misspelling of it and it never works, it is going to
of it and it never works, it is going to
of it and it never works, it is going to be really, really, really hard for me to
be really, really, really hard for me to
be really, really, really hard for me to guide the model in that direction,
guide the model in that direction,
guide the model in that direction, right? Um, so how would I actually go do
right? Um, so how would I actually go do
right? Um, so how would I actually go do this? It turns out the only real way to
this? It turns out the only real way to
this? It turns out the only real way to go do this is you will have to give the
go do this is you will have to give the
go do this is you will have to give the model a name that it can output and then
model a name that it can output and then
model a name that it can output and then convert it post programmatically into
convert it post programmatically into
convert it post programmatically into the name that actually generates. So if
the name that actually generates. So if
the name that actually generates. So if you a model is just a statistical
you a model is just a statistical
you a model is just a statistical distribution of
distribution of
distribution of tokens. So if an if a thing is just
tokens. So if an if a thing is just
tokens. So if an if a thing is just statistically super super super super
statistically super super super super
statistically super super super super unlikely to be the thing that you want
unlikely to be the thing that you want
unlikely to be the thing that you want it to be then you have to fall back
it to be then you have to fall back
it to be then you have to fall back towards techniques like constraint
towards techniques like constraint
towards techniques like constraint generation. you have to fall back
generation. you have to fall back
generation. you have to fall back towards techniques like aliasing where I
towards techniques like aliasing where I
towards techniques like aliasing where I let the model see the content that I
let the model see the content that I
let the model see the content that I want to go see it and then that's the
want to go see it and then that's the
want to go see it and then that's the only real way to navigate that scenario.
only real way to navigate that scenario.
only real way to navigate that scenario. In the case of names, it's a little bit
In the case of names, it's a little bit
In the case of names, it's a little bit more interesting because
more interesting because
more interesting because like so like I just wrote my name
like so like I just wrote my name
like so like I just wrote my name without any
without any
without any vowels or actually I'll do this. My last
vowels or actually I'll do this. My last
vowels or actually I'll do this. My last name is pretty
popular and like we'll just see what the
popular and like we'll just see what the model thinks when I go and go output
model thinks when I go and go output
model thinks when I go and go output name.
name.
name. It might output my name directly. But if
It might output my name directly. But if
It might output my name directly. But if I use a slightly worse
model, see if I can get to or let me
model, see if I can get to or let me try. Yeah, there you go. You got it. It
try. Yeah, there you go. You got it. It
try. Yeah, there you go. You got it. It No, it still output the name correctly.
No, it still output the name correctly.
No, it still output the name correctly. So I want I want I want to show like a
So I want I want I want to show like a
So I want I want I want to show like a slightly worse model like doing dumb
slightly worse model like doing dumb
slightly worse model like doing dumb things with
Smith. So I
Smith. So I want
want
want smit correct.
smit correct.
smit correct. Yeah. Jithgmail.com. And I'll go run
Yeah. Jithgmail.com. And I'll go run
Yeah. Jithgmail.com. And I'll go run this. So in this it's actually doing it
this. So in this it's actually doing it
this. So in this it's actually doing it correctly. But you can imagine a much
correctly. But you can imagine a much
correctly. But you can imagine a much dumber model actually just outputting
dumber model actually just outputting
dumber model actually just outputting John instead of JHN. And the only real
John instead of JHN. And the only real
John instead of JHN. And the only real thing you can do in this scenario is
thing you can do in this scenario is
thing you can do in this scenario is actually in your codebase just write
actually in your codebase just write
actually in your codebase just write another system that just checks and says
another system that just checks and says
another system that just checks and says that the name is actually in one of the
that the name is actually in one of the
that the name is actually in one of the names that you provided. And if it
names that you provided. And if it
names that you provided. And if it isn't, then I make a smaller query that
isn't, then I make a smaller query that
isn't, then I make a smaller query that says what is the exact name from this
says what is the exact name from this
says what is the exact name from this list of names that makes sense and
list of names that makes sense and
list of names that makes sense and actually uh have the model go and
actually uh have the model go and
actually uh have the model go and generate one of those as a corrective
generate one of those as a corrective
generate one of those as a corrective measure because in case the model
measure because in case the model
measure because in case the model doesn't output something that's actually
doesn't output something that's actually
doesn't output something that's actually in your employee database, then you can
in your employee database, then you can
in your employee database, then you can go double check that. That would be the
go double check that. That would be the
go double check that. That would be the approach that I would take in this
approach that I would take in this
approach that I would take in this approach. And like no amount of
approach. And like no amount of
approach. And like no amount of reasoning model or something else can go
reasoning model or something else can go
reasoning model or something else can go fix this because models are just
fix this because models are just
fix this because models are just predictive systems and they will at some
predictive systems and they will at some
predictive systems and they will at some point be wrong and you have to build
point be wrong and you have to build
point be wrong and you have to build systems on top of it to make it correct
systems on top of it to make it correct
systems on top of it to make it correct not just let it go out and hope that it
not just let it go out and hope that it
not just let it go out and hope that it is
is
is correct. Does that answer the question
correct. Does that answer the question
correct. Does that answer the question on above?
on above?
on above? Yes. Yes, I think it does. One one more
Yes. Yes, I think it does. One one more
Yes. Yes, I think it does. One one more question here. So I I see a lot of
question here. So I I see a lot of
question here. So I I see a lot of things happening on grounding LLM using
things happening on grounding LLM using
things happening on grounding LLM using graph and database and especially giving
graph and database and especially giving
graph and database and especially giving your ontologies and business related or
your ontologies and business related or
your ontologies and business related or do domain specific things to it. For
do domain specific things to it. For
do domain specific things to it. For example, I I only have lawyer and super
example, I I only have lawyer and super
example, I I only have lawyer and super lawyer that kind of stuff and then
lawyer that kind of stuff and then
lawyer that kind of stuff and then letting it decide whether someone is
letting it decide whether someone is
letting it decide whether someone is reporting to some other person because
reporting to some other person because
reporting to some other person because these two people are having different
these two people are having different
these two people are having different descriptions on their job post such a
descriptions on their job post such a
descriptions on their job post such a was was there originally a plan to
was was there originally a plan to
was was there originally a plan to discuss this point as well use to ground
discuss this point as well use to ground
discuss this point as well use to ground LM in this call or no? No, I don't think
LM in this call or no? No, I don't think
LM in this call or no? No, I don't think we were going to talk about necessarily
we were going to talk about necessarily
we were going to talk about necessarily graph databases or something here. What
graph databases or something here. What
graph databases or something here. What we really wanted to go do is graph
we really wanted to go do is graph
we really wanted to go do is graph databases are a complex type of query.
databases are a complex type of query.
databases are a complex type of query. So, we just wanted to use that to show
So, we just wanted to use that to show
So, we just wanted to use that to show off like different reasoning techniques
off like different reasoning techniques
off like different reasoning techniques that you could use for graph databases.
that you could use for graph databases.
that you could use for graph databases. I'm probably not the best expert. I
I'm probably not the best expert. I
I'm probably not the best expert. I don't know about that, but like I know
don't know about that, but like I know
don't know about that, but like I know I'm not the best expert on like graph
I'm not the best expert on like graph
I'm not the best expert on like graph databases and like all the different
databases and like all the different
databases and like all the different applications of them. Um, yeah, the idea
applications of them. Um, yeah, the idea
applications of them. Um, yeah, the idea here is I think like for complex things
here is I think like for complex things
here is I think like for complex things that reasoning models are really good at
that reasoning models are really good at
that reasoning models are really good at like coding and like writing queries and
like coding and like writing queries and
like coding and like writing queries and doing these structured things. um that
doing these structured things. um that
doing these structured things. um that there's all these techniques you can use
there's all these techniques you can use
there's all these techniques you can use and so the the using the graph database
and so the the using the graph database
and so the the using the graph database was more of like here's an example of a
was more of like here's an example of a
was more of like here's an example of a thing that reasoning models tend to be
thing that reasoning models tend to be
thing that reasoning models tend to be better at how do we get reasoning model
better at how do we get reasoning model
better at how do we get reasoning model level performance out of a tiny model.
level performance out of a tiny model.
level performance out of a tiny model. Yes. Uh if you if I think if you join
Yes. Uh if you if I think if you join
Yes. Uh if you if I think if you join the B boundary discord and ask Pashant
the B boundary discord and ask Pashant
the B boundary discord and ask Pashant he has a lot of knowledge about graph
he has a lot of knowledge about graph
he has a lot of knowledge about graph databases.
Thanks. Yeah, happy to bounce ideas. I'm
Thanks. Yeah, happy to bounce ideas. I'm right here on the call but I I'm on BAM
right here on the call but I I'm on BAM
right here on the call but I I'm on BAM and Discord as well.
Um, other questions from anyone else
Um, other questions from anyone else that they might want to have answered
that they might want to have answered
that they might want to have answered while we're here. Actually, I I have a
while we're here. Actually, I I have a
while we're here. Actually, I I have a question Weber. So, just to follow up
question Weber. So, just to follow up
question Weber. So, just to follow up with this original question above hand.
with this original question above hand.
with this original question above hand. So, I think I had the same thought when
So, I think I had the same thought when
So, I think I had the same thought when he asked that, which is let's say you
he asked that, which is let's say you
he asked that, which is let's say you had a graph database of uh employees and
had a graph database of uh employees and
had a graph database of uh employees and their skills and BAML was one of those
their skills and BAML was one of those
their skills and BAML was one of those skills and then you issue a query saying
skills and then you issue a query saying
skills and then you issue a query saying give me all the employees who have the
give me all the employees who have the
give me all the employees who have the skill BAML but you misspell BAML as BA B
skill BAML but you misspell BAML as BA B
skill BAML but you misspell BAML as BA B A L M. Yeah. Now LLMs will that's a
A L M. Yeah. Now LLMs will that's a
A L M. Yeah. Now LLMs will that's a classic case where the misspelling is a
classic case where the misspelling is a
classic case where the misspelling is a correct term and the correct spelling is
correct term and the correct spelling is
correct term and the correct spelling is the is the misunderstood term right so
the is the misunderstood term right so
the is the misunderstood term right so in that situation your your LLM is going
in that situation your your LLM is going
in that situation your your LLM is going to actually search for bum and it's
to actually search for bum and it's
to actually search for bum and it's going to fail because you're going to
going to fail because you're going to
going to fail because you're going to get an empty response from that sit from
get an empty response from that sit from
get an empty response from that sit from the database t right this would be like
the database t right this would be like
the database t right this would be like if we misspelled ke ree name right
if we misspelled ke ree name right
if we misspelled ke ree name right search for exist yeah so so the point is
search for exist yeah so so the point is
search for exist yeah so so the point is I notic in the implementation that you
I notic in the implementation that you
I notic in the implementation that you you have decks it's just giving you
you have decks it's just giving you
you have decks it's just giving you empty results all the time in an
empty results all the time in an
empty results all the time in an infinite loop it's just not doing
infinite loop it's just not doing
infinite loop it's just not doing anything after the empty result So the
anything after the empty result So the
anything after the empty result So the right way to handle this would be
right way to handle this would be
right way to handle this would be something like you have a fallback where
something like you have a fallback where
something like you have a fallback where if you don't get like this uh if you get
if you don't get like this uh if you get
if you don't get like this uh if you get an empty result you don't assume that
an empty result you don't assume that
an empty result you don't assume that the information does not exist you try
the information does not exist you try
the information does not exist you try the query in a different form uh in a
the query in a different form uh in a
the query in a different form uh in a way that the you at least try from a
way that the you at least try from a
way that the you at least try from a different perspective because the issue
different perspective because the issue
different perspective because the issue is that you don't know whether the
is that you don't know whether the
is that you don't know whether the answer is wrong missing or in uh correct
answer is wrong missing or in uh correct
answer is wrong missing or in uh correct like there's three possibilities right
like there's three possibilities right
like there's three possibilities right exactly so there's no real way for you
exactly so there's no real way for you
exactly so there's no real way for you to know that unless you potentially like
to know that unless you potentially like
to know that unless you potentially like especially when you have an empty result
especially when you have an empty result
especially when you have an empty result you don't know whether it's wrong or
you don't know whether it's wrong or
you don't know whether it's wrong or missing
missing
missing Yeah. So you could come here and check
Yeah. So you could come here and check
Yeah. So you could come here and check and say like if if the result is empty,
and say like if if the result is empty,
and say like if if the result is empty, you can instead push something into the
you can instead push something into the
you can instead push something into the context that is like you did. Beautiful
context that is like you did. Beautiful
context that is like you did. Beautiful example. Yeah. Reb had a really good
example. Yeah. Reb had a really good
example. Yeah. Reb had a really good example of this in the Neo Forj stream
example of this in the Neo Forj stream
example of this in the Neo Forj stream that he did with the Neo Forj people. Uh
that he did with the Neo Forj people. Uh
that he did with the Neo Forj people. Uh that's something I highly recommend
that's something I highly recommend
that's something I highly recommend whoever's on this call, please go and
whoever's on this call, please go and
whoever's on this call, please go and watch that one because uh the way you
watch that one because uh the way you
watch that one because uh the way you handle the retry and you know preventing
handle the retry and you know preventing
handle the retry and you know preventing failure modes when you have misspellings
failure modes when you have misspellings
failure modes when you have misspellings or typos or whatever other minor issues,
or typos or whatever other minor issues,
or typos or whatever other minor issues, those are different ways to think about
those are different ways to think about
those are different ways to think about it.
Oh, let me try again. Yeah, just making
Oh, let me try again. Yeah, just making an assistant message.
an assistant message.
an assistant message. And now you're kind of done.
And now you're kind of done.
And now you're kind of done. So, we can actually add like a special
So, we can actually add like a special
So, we can actually add like a special thing into here that adds that in for
thing into here that adds that in for
thing into here that adds that in for the user that says we actually forcibly
the user that says we actually forcibly
the user that says we actually forcibly add this into the context where we say
add this into the context where we say
add this into the context where we say something like, oh, the query didn't
something like, oh, the query didn't
something like, oh, the query didn't result return any results. Perhaps it's
result return any results. Perhaps it's
result return any results. Perhaps it's wrong. W wrong or
wrong. W wrong or
wrong. W wrong or misspelled.
misspelled.
misspelled. Uh should we ask the user for more?
Uh should we ask the user for more?
Uh should we ask the user for more? Right. You're injecting thoughts
Right. You're injecting thoughts
Right. You're injecting thoughts for
for
for more information there. Yeah. This is
more information there. Yeah. This is
more information there. Yeah. This is this is kind of what you Yeah. had
this is kind of what you Yeah. had
this is kind of what you Yeah. had before. This is a good one. And now what
before. This is a good one. And now what
before. This is a good one. And now what can happen is I'm actually injecting
can happen is I'm actually injecting
can happen is I'm actually injecting stuff into the context that comes again
stuff into the context that comes again
stuff into the context that comes again from me from all of us kind of knowing
from me from all of us kind of knowing
from me from all of us kind of knowing upfront that this is a this is a
upfront that this is a this is a
upfront that this is a this is a contextual application built around
contextual application built around
contextual application built around talking to a graph database and that
talking to a graph database and that
talking to a graph database and that these kinds of things where it's
these kinds of things where it's
these kinds of things where it's empty might
empty might
empty might uh might not not for sure might uh be
uh might not not for sure might uh be
uh might not not for sure might uh be wrong. But you can't do this generically
wrong. But you can't do this generically
wrong. But you can't do this generically if that makes sense.
Yep. Makes total sense. Cool. You can
Yep. Makes total sense. Cool. You can Yeah.
Yeah.
Yeah. Um cool. Super interesting. What What
Um cool. Super interesting. What What
Um cool. Super interesting. What What else we got?
Awesome. Um I think that's it for this
Awesome. Um I think that's it for this time. Uh next week we're going to have a
time. Uh next week we're going to have a
time. Uh next week we're going to have a really really fun conversation about a
really really fun conversation about a
really really fun conversation about a topic that I am personally really
topic that I am personally really
topic that I am personally really excited about. Um, you have a thing
excited about. Um, you have a thing
excited about. Um, you have a thing available on under on there uh text.
available on under on there uh text.
available on under on there uh text. Okay, I'll pull it up. Oh, you want
Okay, I'll pull it up. Oh, you want
Okay, I'll pull it up. Oh, you want Yeah. You want to pull up the uh the
Yeah. You want to pull up the uh the
Yeah. You want to pull up the uh the card? Yeah. Which is I think
card? Yeah. Which is I think
card? Yeah. Which is I think um or are you pulling up? I can pull it
um or are you pulling up? I can pull it
um or are you pulling up? I can pull it up. Yeah, go for it. Which I think is
up. Yeah, go for it. Which I think is
up. Yeah, go for it. Which I think is going to be something that is really
going to be something that is really
going to be something that is really relevant to a lot of people as we go
relevant to a lot of people as we go
relevant to a lot of people as we go forward, which is people talk a lot
forward, which is people talk a lot
forward, which is people talk a lot about like fine-tuning and how we can go
about like fine-tuning and how we can go
about like fine-tuning and how we can go do this. Um, this one is going to be a
do this. Um, this one is going to be a
do this. Um, this one is going to be a lot more conceptual on how we can
lot more conceptual on how we can
lot more conceptual on how we can actually leverage human feedback and how
actually leverage human feedback and how
actually leverage human feedback and how we have to collect data in a way for our
we have to collect data in a way for our
we have to collect data in a way for our AI pipelines so we can fix them with rag
AI pipelines so we can fix them with rag
AI pipelines so we can fix them with rag versus fine-tuning.
versus fine-tuning.
versus fine-tuning. That's that's in two weeks, I think.
That's that's in two weeks, I think.
That's that's in two weeks, I think. Unless we're switching the schedule
Unless we're switching the schedule
Unless we're switching the schedule around. Oh, sorry. No, no, sorry. Yes,
around. Oh, sorry. No, no, sorry. Yes,
around. Oh, sorry. No, no, sorry. Yes, that's the last one. Oh, I I was I was
that's the last one. Oh, I I was I was
that's the last one. Oh, I I was I was blown away. We're gonna talk about code
blown away. We're gonna talk about code
blown away. We're gonna talk about code generation. I think code generation will
generation. I think code generation will
generation. I think code generation will be a really fun one. Yeah, I agree. Um,
be a really fun one. Yeah, I agree. Um,
be a really fun one. Yeah, I agree. Um, but um excited to see you all again.
but um excited to see you all again.
but um excited to see you all again. Thank you all for joining. Uh, see you
Thank you all for joining. Uh, see you
Thank you all for joining. Uh, see you again next Tuesday. Yeah. Thanks y'all.
again next Tuesday. Yeah. Thanks y'all.
again next Tuesday. Yeah. Thanks y'all. This was super fun.
This was super fun.
This was super fun. Fun.